You don't feel,
oh,
it is filming.
You're filming right now,
but you are online.
Eddie,
if this is real,
this is live.
I'm nervous now,
whenever we're live in your heart skips a beat thinking it's people listening to
this shit.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
You know all about it.
By now.
If you tune into this podcast,
if you don't know about it,
it looks like a flashlight,
but you can fuck it.
John.
Half Ron had the best line.
He said,
it's great they should incorporate it with a flashlight because nobody ever
knows where the flashlight is,
but everybody knows where their fleshlight is and he's so right.
It's so true.
It's a genius analysis by Mr Half.
Ron,
a fine comedian.
Follow him on Twitter.
Will Ya?
H G F R o n.
John Half Ron our buddy.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight.
Enter in the code name Rog,
and save yourself some money.
All right.
How much?
15% God damn.
Are you serious?
Yes,
I am.
Go.
This is the tipping point.
This is it's time to make the decision.
John Heffrons been in in my,
hey,
where the fuck is that dude?
It's been on the road for like,
he's 32.
He's an animal.
He's,
he's somewhere doing pushups in the fucking parking lot.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n,
n.
I,
t,
makers of Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom tech sport and shroom tech,
immune Alpha brain being the most famous and also the most controversial.
It is a cognitive enhancing supplement,
a nootropic.
If you go online and Google nootropic,
that's and o,
t,
r.
O,
you could spell the rest.
It's a,
uh,
they're what they are as vitamins that have been shown to improve your body's
ability to produce neuro transmitters that don't make you smarter if you're
stupid,
but they do enhance the way your brain works.
I use them,
I believe in them and we have a 100% money back guarantee on your first order.
If you were to 30 pills and you don't like it,
you don't even have to return the product.
We're not trying to rip anybody off.
This is all stuff that before we were selling in this,
I used all of it and I used all of it cause it works.
I'm a big believer in vitamins and supplements and I'm a big believer in that.
What you take into your body affects the way your brain works for sure.
Um,
puts you brains.
Yeah you do.
He's taken a lot of pussy in your body.
How you doing that?
Really Long.
Something creepy about singing,
eating pussy like age.
I'm thinking of chewing and swallowing.
It's something you know a girl can suck a cock and that's totally right.
When you're eating pussy it's like,
it just sounds like you're chewing,
especially when it's like a fat guy and you think of him like being hungry and
he's eating pussy and he's just like,
you think he's just going to take a bite out of it.
I wonder if like if he really ate pussy,
if it was like the most delicious piece of
bolts,
probably print a tender season.
You'd have to make sure you didn't cook it very fast.
He like salt and vinegar.
Potato chips.
You would have to be like a searing,
just black and blue it.
Yeah.
I found out about blue sticks this weekend in Atlanta for the first time.
How do you order at a restaurant?
And they,
there was rare and then it said blue and I was like,
what the fuck is blue?
So this is the coolest shit ever.
I tweet Anthony Bordain and Anthony Bordain tweets me the answer.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
how great is this world that we live in?
Yeah.
What?
What was the steak place?
So it was twice in the four seasons in Atlanta.
I don't remember the name.
I know it or no,
wait,
is it chop?
I don't remember.
But he's really good.
He's placed in Atlanta.
You've got to be a member to get in.
Oh,
cheese.
And it's got like at the restaurant,
but then there's a member's room.
It's the best steak I've ever had my whole life.
Anyway,
this is the end of the commercial.
We always do this,
don't,
oh,
sorry.
No,
don't apologize.
This is every single week we do it.
The the,
yes,
do it.
We try not to make our commercials too commercially and in the process they
become conversations about shit sometimes like eating pussy and the best take in
Atlanta,
but I,
but I still want to take the product now.
It's good stuff.
I'll get it for you on a.com go check it out.
And again,
if you order something you don't like it,
you don't have to even return the product.
We are absolutely not trying to rip anybody off.
Everything we're selling is the highest level ingredients that are possible to
acquire.
It's the best stuff we know how to make.
It's real.
I use it.
Go check it out on and.com and enter in the code named Brogan and you'd get
yourself 10% off any and all orders,
not just the first one.
All right.
You dirty fucking bitches
experience Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Nick Diaz is will always be the greatest.
Shout out the Roivant.
Donald wanted people who were criticizing it and like you crazy bitch.
That's Rory Macdonald talking about my podcast.
That must stay in,
but Nick Diaz just nailed it.
Train by day.
Joe Rogan podcast.
I always wondered who that was.
Nick motherfucking is
my favorite fighter to ever test positive for weed,
but a good guy
fucking so stupid.
Not only that,
he didn't even really test positive for wheat.
He tested positive for an inactive metabolite.
It's not a psychoactive,
it's evidence that some cannabis has been in this system,
but it's not evidence of marijuana.
It's evidence of an inactive metabolite.
That's all it is.
So it does.
You could have taken this inactive metabolite,
which isn't even prevented or a prohibited by the Nevada State Athletic
Commission.
So why so it didn't matter.
It's also be,
besides the possibility of taking it that way,
you can also get some,
you can,
no,
no.
You can get it from marijuana.
It's not a masking issue.
I think it's a flushing issue.
I don't think you can mask marijuana approved.
I mean,
I know you're out there.
There's something that can tell me,
but I'm saying why would that,
that's not a performance enhancing drug.
Well,
it's a PR somehow or another.
What they're saying.
I believe if I understand the legal language,
I think what they're saying is that the metabolites shows that he has had it in
his system.
But what's really crazy is it's so stupid because they know he's a patient.
He's a medical marijuana patient in California,
and if you don't know that Nick Diaz smokes weed,
Jesus Christ,
are you paying attention at
all?
You don't know he smokes weed.
So what?
It's okay if he stops 13 days,
but not 1211 days,
but not ten nine days,
but not age.
Shut the fuck up.
It's fucking stupid.
You know why?
Because what you're talking about is not him being high inside the octagon.
The psychoactive effects of marijuana don't exist when he's in that octagon
with,
with those levels,
it's impossible.
So he's 100% sober.
That should be the question.
You know he was taking it before that because he's got a card.
So when is it?
Where's this logical cutoffs?
That's crazy.
Like the HGH thing,
you know the NFL is trying to good luck.
Yeah,
it's so fucking crazy.
I've been reading so much about it because I do a podcast called Wad cast about
crossfit.
Oh Dude.
Yeah.
And across the place just opened up like 10 miles away from their opening
fucking bathrooms at Starbucks.
They're everywhere.
But they,
their tests,
they say they tested the games and like 68,000 people tried out for the games
this year.
Right.
And uh,
these guys,
like if you look at the guys that are the top crossfitters,
some people say they don't use,
some people say they could.
I'm not here to say if they do or don't,
but they're doing like four and five workouts a day.
They're just insane.
They're,
they're,
they're inhuman and,
and just the recovery rate I'm looking at going fucking HGH would be amazing.
But when they test,
they test the same way the NFL does,
which you can't,
you can't catch it in the urine test.
Only like one time in the world.
Has anyone gotten caught in an HGH?
You're in test.
It was like a rugby player in the UK.
Oh,
at one time.
One time in a year.
And totally crazy levels or something.
Yeah.
Something was wrong was just completely white.
So they have this new system that they think they're going to be able to test.
But we had Sean Waxman who is the Olympic weightlifting code.
He's got Waxman's Jim down by the airport.
We had him on the other day and he was talking about how it's,
it's uh,
more of like a moneymaking thing.
Like there's money being made in the,
in the testing world is,
so there's like lobbying being done to make more testing and more testing so
they can make more money because it's just this ridiculous,
I'm a firm believer.
Why would you prevent people from enhancing themselves?
Like,
like you let people take protein supplements that's coming from a cow.
We're taking the way from a cow and we're eating it to make ourselves better.
Why can't we take the growth hormone from a cadaver and use that?
We don't do that at first of all.
Because if you did do that,
you can get really sick and you can get fucking mad cow disease.
What we were talking about earlier,
you can get all sorts of crazy diseases.
Well,
where did,
you might say it's a synthetic,
right?
Yes,
but it's actually made by bacteria.
It is bacteria.
Bacteria constructed well,
but it's so,
it's a s anything that simulates the amazing process that you and I would never
figure it out.
Give it a billion years at all the books in the world.
You and I would still be sitting around telling fart jokes.
We would never figure it how to make a lot further ahead than I would.
I were moans,
Syria.
Oh my God.
Fuck it.
I can't figure out how a toilet works.
It's an amazing how some people's minds just can do that.
Like there's,
it's a variation in the way that the human mind works is so spectacular.
I tried to figure out,
I was watching the way they're testing to figure out how the,
the human growth hormone load the weight.
They've got this like thing that locks onto it so that they can test and I was
watching over and over trying to,
trying to comprehend it.
I could,
unlike,
I'm fucking retard.
I can't get this in my head.
Rick Ross would have figured it out.
You probably would have went the real request that we had on yesterday.
Genius Guy that the,
the uh,
the drug dealer,
it was a yeah,
till he was 28 years old.
He couldn't read really.
Not only did he teach himself how to read,
but he also taught himself the law and found loopholes in the law.
So he went from being like,
can't even read a book,
Jack and Jill to fucking getting himself out of a life term in prison.
Fucking what was,
um,
one of the most amazing,
I think the best podcasts.
It's just the story wise,
it was just amazing.
And then some rubbers,
kind of his identity.
One rappers stole his identity.
That would piss me off.
Yeah.
You'd think,
I mean they thought it was going to be in jail for life is what it was.
He was a legend out on the street.
Uh,
like you know,
I had heard his name,
so he's very heard his name when I was living in La.
I wasn't even living in la rather when I heard his name,
like he was that legendary.
Oh yeah.
He was legendary as far as like drug dealers in this country.
You would hear him on them and the new stores and stuff,
when he won his trial was going on.
So huge,
huge deal.
Nationwide was a huge,
how'd you guys find him?
Cause he,
he's look now
it was at Rick Ross or did the wrapper of that?
It was a,
no,
he's a freeway.
Ricky on Twitter.
That's what his nickname was,
freeway Ricky Ross.
But he,
uh,
you know,
it's really interesting to see this guy who was 20 years old in this terrible
situation and sort of just kind of found his way through the system to success.
And then it all came,
fallen apart and then he built himself back up again and now he's like a really
cool dude.
It's amazing.
Really intense,
intense story.
Pissed off about the guy stealing his identity.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
You should be the then,
well,
we can't talk about it.
There's,
there's part of it that we can't talk about for legal issues.
So there's a,
there's a guy in Australia,
I don't know if you've ever seen the movie chopper.
Yes,
I have.
I love that fucking movie.
It's Eric Bana.
[inaudible]
supposedly all true.
Yeah.
I mean,
this guy,
if you haven't seen the film,
the guy got thrown in prison,
he was like,
he was like a hit man kind of for drug dealers.
He gets thrown in prison and they're going to send them to like the wing of the
prison where the guys that want to kill him are.
So instead of going there,
he cut his own ears off so that they'd put them in the crazy ward.
And now he's got these like fucked up years.
But what a great idea.
But he's,
he's just crazy,
legendary Australia and the people kind of like,
he's,
he's like a folk hero on that.
But there was,
there's a guy now on the fuck up,
there's a guy who does a parody of them and does a show and tours
to like sold out shows everywhere.
And,
and uh,
and I just did his show,
like he does a show where he hosts it and he,
I did the Adelaide comedy festival and I did his show.
It's a late night.
It's a heath.
Franklin is the guy.
He does chopper it,
but he,
he plays chopper and he's in character doing standup and it's good.
It's good.
Stand up.
And then he's doing it as chopper and every joke is about like misogyny and
fucking harden the fuck up and,
and he's got the mustache on and the sunglasses and I set afterwards because I
had heard rumors,
I said is,
has he ever contacted you?
And he goes,
yeah,
yeah.
Apparently he's not very happy.
I go,
why don't you fuck with a guy like that?
Christ the guy who will come in.
You're not in your wheelhouse.
Crazy.
It's fucking crazy.
If you watch the movie,
by the way,
if you haven't seen it,
it's a great movie.
It's really fun.
Amazing.
You're rooting for this.
Psychopath Australia makes great co like criminal can crime films like that.
They have,
they have a show or they had a movie called Animal House Watch.
Animal House about this family.
I have the,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's fucking great.
Explain how he gets to do that.
If choppers still alive.
I don't know.
I said,
do you have to pay him a commission?
Do you nothing.
Tours and sells out shows everywhere.
Reason.
That seems crazy.
That seems like you're asking for trouble.
You should give that guy a piece.
Well,
I mean I guess it's kind of the same.
I mean it's like guys that do impressions.
I mean that's the way he does it,
but it's a full sun impression.
That's why I'm just going to change my name.
Did Louie Anderson?
If I have to do anywhere else,
I'll come down hard on you.
Louie.
Louie will come down hard on your son,
both of you.
What are you saying and why are you saying it on the Internet?
Like spanking.
I was getting nervous on your show because your fans are so diligent about
facts.
Too brutal.
They're brutal.
Twitter's like last time I was here I was talking about grass fed meat stuff.
He's like,
cows or pigs can't be grass fed.
They get sunburned.
They do some of that.
They do.
If you think about it,
this pink pigs he's like so they have to be under so they can't be eating grass
all the time.
That totally makes sense.
Yeah.
I would think where the real pink like that.
What kind of protection from the sun is that you?
I don't know.
They'd probably get all fucked up.
Cause imagine ribbons,
Suntan lotion all over the cow.
Pig Man.
A Perry got a cow.
Pigs are so weird because pigs are the only animal that we know of that becomes
feral.
Meaning it becomes wild almost immediately from the release from a farm and it
actually physically changes shape.
It's real weird.
There are for changes,
it becomes like darker and thicker and Busher and their tusks grow longer and
their snout actually grows long.
Maybe that's how they should naturally be.
But so weird though that.
Why doesn't that happen when they're in the best case?
Cause they're probably feeding them shitty food.
I don't know if that's it,
man.
Somebody told me what's the best way to get rid of a body?
It's just
pigs in the way the movie snatch.
Okay.
Did they do it?
Not.
Yeah,
I remember the guy was a eeky or I'm like,
all right,
we keep some pigs.
Yeah,
that guy was a great action with those shoot super coke bottle glasses like I
was the shit wasn't in the sopranos also or am I just thinking match?
I definitely in snap,
but you know,
but that's a,
I asked a guy once,
he's gotten rid of a body,
I said,
what's the best way to get rid of a body?
And he said go fishing.
And I said,
what?
He goes,
go fishing and throw them in the water.
Like you go far enough out in the ocean if you're lucky,
if you're not lucky,
not lucky.
That bitch floats to shore up your tying up here.
You got to tie him up.
Dexter style,
pubic hair of yours doesn't it?
But if you think about it,
I mean it's probably a good bet.
I mean there's a lot of God damn real estate out there.
What people are buried out there.
How many people do you think are buried on the weight in Nevada?
Oh God,
that's crazy.
Dirt road.
Those off to the side where you see like we're dirt roads through the chicken
wire.
Like what is that?
What's going on back there?
Who owns that checks that for bodies.
Who skins that they were the fucking metal.
The sexy looking for watches.
The people that got burnt up.
I think it's funny when they find one,
remember that bodybuilder?
I was just about to bring that up.
Chris Titus.
Yes.
Didn't he tried?
No.
Chris Titus was no immediate immediate.
Craig situs said it.
What's his name?
No,
it's all on my shit wrong.
He killed his personal assistant.
He and his wife,
because he was fucking her I think.
And his wife,
his wife caught them and so I guess he and his wife decided to get rid of her.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the best way to handle getting caught cheating.
And they killed her and then they took her out to the desert.
Craig Titus and they were going to like light the Er.
They were lighting on fire and air or,
yeah,
the car and her and me.
I remember this guy,
he was,
he was so juice to the gills.
You're so crazy that he would actually,
it was like challenging Phil Baroni who was saying that he wanted to fight Phil
Baroni when Phil Baroni was,
uh,
you know,
feel brony when he was young was one of the scariest knockout punches in the,
in the UFC middleweight division.
He didn't beat like a lot of the top guys,
but he's a tough motherfucker for some crazy body builder to come along and say
that,
you know,
go watch that Dave [inaudible] fight.
Go Watch Phil Baroni light.
Dave Manet up with like 15 punches in a row while standing while he's already
unconscious.
He doesn't even have a chance to hit the ground and broke his hip.
I'm not kidding,
man.
It's one of the greatest highlight,
real chaos of all time and this fucking Douche bag Jews head who just lifts
weights,
thinks he's going to fuck with that.
Like it's hilarious.
This guy's,
they get so full of testosterone and there's so,
I mean,
they're literally not even human anymore.
If you see as some of those guys when they hit those crazy levels of
testosterone that you need to get that big.
I used to work out at that goal.
Jim and his,
his picture was on the wall.
He was one of the guys they want to in Venice and not human.
Like the day that happened,
I think I was in there and the guy was on a ladder pulling the picture.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Yeah,
that
he's a disgrace.
But I mean like when you get like that big,
like Lee Haney big,
come on man.
That's not human.
It's not,
you can't,
it's,
it's an insult.
But it would also feel like,
like I'm a little guy,
I weigh like 170 pounds and I,
I work out a lot.
I do crossfit like six days a week.
And when I started here frequently,
yeah.
When I start to work out where I'm doing a lot of Olympic lifting and power
lifting and stuff,
where I start to get a little heavier and up to blink 180 my,
I feel uncomfortable,
you know,
just like losing all my mobility and everything.
I can't,
they're,
they,
they're like handicapped.
That's also an issue of what you're doing for exercise.
If you wanted mobility,
you should be nodded.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but not at that size.
Do heavyweights.
Sure.
But I do a lot everything,
you know,
I do a lot of metcons and stuff,
but they,
I'm saying when you get to that bodybuilder size,
like Lee Haney size,
you lose,
you're almost like a handicapped person when you're taking your shirt on.
You'd be amazed at how well some guys can move with a lot of muscle that have
stretched out.
Yeah.
That's really what it is.
It's all about like flexibility and it's all,
there's guys like,
there's this kid named Todd Duffy,
he's a heavyweight contender and he probably weighs,
I'd say weighs around two 40 ish,
somewhere in that looks like a fucking like some sort of a,
an action comic hero.
It doesn't really,
we were real human and he's huge.
He's just swollen muscles everywhere.
And this mother fucker moves like a cat.
Like it's creepy to watch them.
It's creepy to watch them jump on dudes and punch them cause you're like,
Jesus,
he's not supposed to move that quick.
Like it's uncomfortable and one of the reasons why he can move so quick as he's
a real athlete stretches everything and he doesn't just do you if you're doing
Olympic cleans,
if you're doing dead lifts and if you're doing like power squats you at whatever
time you spend doing that,
you should spend twice that amount of time stretching out and getting deep
tissue massage.
Yeah.
So for every two hours you're lifting,
it should be four hours,
two hours deep tissue in two hours stretching.
That's not bullshit.
You like you really need to stretch everything.
It takes a long time.
I that I don't fuck around cause when I first got into crossfit I thought it was
cool that you'll need to work out for like sometimes three minutes.
The workouts are sometimes three minutes.
Yeah.
If you,
if you're good at it,
like a friend,
a good friend time is three is three minutes of Fran Fran who would be a 95
pound thruster 21 times.
Then 20 a thruster has a structure,
is a,
we got to clean it first.
Then you go into a squat and then end up push press over your head.
Okay.
So you do that 21 times,
then you go straight to the pull up bar 21 times,
then you do 15 thrusters,
15 pull ups,
then nine thrusters,
nine pullups.
Okay,
so that's like 90 reps or something.
But you're doing who'd done,
yeah,
you're,
you're fucking done.
And,
and uh,
you know,
they have that scheme rep gain with like you could do it with like handstand
pushups and dead lifts,
which
is,
is a pretty tough one to,
uh,
and it was all just blowing it out,
blown out.
Some of them are up to 20 minutes long,
some of them are,
you know,
like fight gone bad.
Uh,
what's his name?
The,
the wrestler or the the UFC fighter did,
I think it was Dana White did it with the crossfit.
They put it together and they said,
let's simulate a UFC fight.
So it's like,
what are you,
five minutes and then,
or what's around three five minute rounds?
So it's,
and how many?
Three three in them,
the regular fights and five and championship and main event fights.
So this is like five,
five minute rounds with one minute break and in between each one and you row.
Then you do push presses,
box jumps,
everything and you do as many reps as you can get in of these things like a
minute each and then you switch to the next thing for a minute and it's five
things in five minutes.
Then you take a minute break five and they asked him afterwards and they're
like,
what was that like?
Was that like a fight?
He goes,
it was like a fight gone bat and it just,
it beats the fuck out of you.
But I used to go into the gym without warming up thinking I could do it.
Oh God.
And,
and I could.
But then I developed so many issues with like bad back bad.
Let me bring this up then because tendinitis,
Steve Maxwell is a guy that I trained with a bunch of times of a brilliant guy,
really well known for being a fitness guru,
and he thinks that those high repetition,
dead lift things that get done a lot in crossfit.
He said,
you're not supposed to do that.
That's not how those exercises are designed.
Yes,
yes.
Potential for injury.
Yes and no.
I mean,
I'm sitting here right now with,
I've got a bad disc because I did 155 pound power clean or squat,
squat.
What was it?
155 pound dude.
Once you stop fucking around and take Jujitsu,
just learners,
triangle people.
I don't like the roll around with men.
I'm the little,
when you choke the fuck,
listen man,
I do have aggression.
I do probably like that.
Well,
yeah,
you would love it.
You're a man.
You,
it would help you tremendously.
You're so into fitness,
but you're not even getting the rewards.
I know they're getting a skill.
These workout I did the other day,
it was 155 pound a squat clean and jerk 30 times as fast as you can do it to see
that's where it,
Maxwell has an issue with it.
He's,
he's his issue is that when you're doing these high rep exercises,
there's just too much potential for fuckups.
Here's he's right then,
and I hurt myself because I am talking to Sean Waxman who was an Olympic lifting
like expert,
you know,
he was like a national champion or whatever.
He,
I don't have my technique.
I mean that's a high technique thing.
If you're an Olympic weight lifter,
it has to be so precise.
It's like fucking ballet.
How good you have to be.
[inaudible] when they have that woman,
they locked her arms overhead and squatted,
it's overhead press and the fucking bar is like way too heavy for them.
You know,
they just got up there with trickery.
they did some,
they did that crazy Natchez fucking unbelievable.
It's wiggling over the head.
You're like,
my God,
if that falls in your skull,
your duns dead done dead.
And,
uh,
I saw a GoGet
crushed by a a bench ones.
He was benching and went away over his head and he fucking,
his arm just gave out and it comes down on him hard.
It goes to his neck,
everybody's screaming,
they're running over and pull up the weights off of them.
It was fucking pen
pneumonia.
You can spend five hours on youtube crying your eyes out laughing at
weightlifting nails.
And the best is the guys passing out after a lift.
That's the funniest dude.
Like a big dead lifted fall forward on his face.
Guys have died from that.
Guys have had hernias or rather aneurysm.
I had a one time in the middle of a workout I had,
I think it was an exertion headache or something.
We're just,
I knew like an,
I try never to quit.
I just looked at everyone and I went,
I'm out,
I'm out.
Cause my head started like pulsating.
Ooo,
and and it was a lot that they teach you to like,
you know,
a lot of times you were taught like breathe in and then on the downward,
on the,
on the ecentric and on the concentric you,
you exhale.
But a lot of times in our kind of lifting they say hold your breath because it
locks your core.
If you hold your breath throughout the whole lift,
like bogged down.
And then once you finish the lift,
exhale,
it locks your core together,
locks your spine and it keeps more control.
So like just hold,
take a deep breath,
hold on the way down.
Hold on the way up.
Exhale.
So I was doing that and all of sudden it was like,
like I popped something in my head and I went,
fuck,
I'm going to die.
I really thought aneurism or something and I went to was just a little mini one.
Don't tell me that.
Cause aneurysms.
Well actually that's the way to go.
That's the,
you're out.
You're dead,
you're gone.
You learned my grandmother.
Aw.
My grandmother had an aneurysm.
They gave her 72 hours.
She lived 12 years.
But she has Sicilian peasant genetics.
There's fucking those peasant genes,
those brick carrying savages that's uh,
a hardy people.
She survived.
Aw.
Yeah.
You know,
no one ever took care of them.
How their health,
everyone's just eating Italian food.
It was always meat balls and Lasagna.
I would go over their house.
It was just ridiculous.
My grandmother always made homemade pasta,
homemade,
everything.
Everything was fucking sausages.
[inaudible] sauce.
And it was just aneurisms.
It was just called cholesterol.
It's like,
oh wait.
Natha how's the,
she,
she lived for 12 years.
My grandfather had to take care of her.
It was a,
it was amazing to watch,
man.
It was amazing to watch.
It was one time,
this is really,
I mean it's very sentimental,
but it was,
he was standing over and she couldn't wipe her ass.
She couldn't do anything.
Man.
She had bed sores.
He had a Turner to make sure that she didn't have bed sores.
You had to,
and she would still get them.
You know,
she's in bed all the time.
It's constantly rubbing up for 12 years,
12 years.
And she could barely,
she was barely lucid and she would make crazy noises and sometimes she was there
and sometimes she wasn't.
But she was essentially trapped in her own body for the rest of her days.
And um,
it was hard,
man,
because I was living with them at the time for a little bit when I first moved
to New York,
didn't have enough money for my own apartment and my grandparents lived in New
Jersey,
north New Jersey.
They had been there since like the 30s when it was an all Italian neighborhood.
And now it's become this like hodgepodge of like third world people and really
poor black people.
It's like,
it's not a good neighborhood at all by any stretch of the imagination.
And My,
uh,
you know,
they'd just stayed,
it just had become their neighborhood and they just dealt with it.
And my grandmother was just in a bed all the time,
moaning.
Oh,
just in agony and pain.
And one time she says to my grandfather,
liked you too good to me.
Like,
I don't deserve you.
Like she,
she,
she was lucid and like she could,
yeah,
some code talker.
Sometimes she would say something like that,
but it was really garbled.
I got,
want to do an impression of it out of respect,
but it sounded like someone who was pretty fucked up.
It didn't sound like the way I just said it,
like,
you're too good to me.
She couldn't talk like that.
It was,
it was a long drawn out.
It was difficult to get the sentence out.
You know?
He told her he loved her and she was his wife.
It was pretty crazy.
It was made me cry and then she died.
It was one of those classic things when she died,
he died a year later.
Yeah.
My grandparents did that.
My grandmother is 96,
96.
They both lived to and uh,
and uh,
he died and she went right after,
right after.
No,
we'll just went all the way to 96.
And it was like,
what else is there?
There's no,
well,
I mean,
you know,
and it's like,
that's what life was supposed to be.
It's supposed to be get to a point where it's really,
you know,
you're,
you're accepting the fact that it's over because it's not good anymore.
Yeah.
You ever read the book?
Uh,
oh.
What's his name?
The guy who wrote man's search for meaning?
No,
I'm okay.
It's
a guy.
He,
he,
victor,
Victor,
Victor Hugo.
I think he,
uh,
he was in a concentration camp and he made it all the way through and he wrote
this book on Low logo therapy,
I think it's called our logo therapy.
And he,
he,
it was amazing because he talked about all the people that survived and how they
survived the concentration camp been like stripped completely naked,
having your hair shaved off your head,
put in like losing your identity,
having no identity and being able to survive that,
like being stripped of everything in life that you ever had and you're having
your whole,
most of these people,
their whole families were killed,
were murdered.
So like what do you live for?
And I think that happened to him.
His entire family was killed.
So some people would still have someone,
they'd be like,
I want to live to get back to my wife or I want to live to get back to my child.
His was,
I want to live to get back to help people,
to show people how to get through something this atrocious.
Like,
like that.
That was his will.
But he said you had to have something.
If you didn't have something you wouldn't make it.
And he talks about the,
the most amazing thing he talked about was going,
uh,
how he said sufferings,
like a gas.
It'll fill a room no matter how big it is.
And he said like,
they were on the one train going to one of the concentration camps.
And like if you go over this bridge,
you were going to the one where they kill you.
But if you make like a right turn,
you're going to the one where you're going to stay alive for a couple more
weeks.
It's a work camp and they're in the truck and he said like cattle,
you know,
they've got them all pressed together.
You can't breathe your smell like shit and you're smothered and,
and it's all these other like concentration camp victims and uh,
you're,
you're in there and it's the worst like worse like place you could ever be in
your life.
Like,
like mentally,
physically and you're going over this and you thinking I'm going to die.
I'm going over this bridge and we're going to the death camp.
But they made like a right turn to go to the work camp for two weeks and there
was like a cheer in,
in the truck,
like in the,
the car,
the train car.
That was like the greatest feeling in the world because they had two more weeks
to live.
Like they,
they weren't going to die.
And he said it's amazing that like you can be in that shitty of a position in
your life,
but experience have that like elation that so high like,
and it's,
it's kind of Buddhist about like live in the moment.
I mean,
you're in a horrible,
horrible place,
but you can have these levels of like,
like,
fuck,
that was like fucking amazing.
I just fucking like,
like,
like you remember the high highs of your life and one of them was at the lowest
point of your life.
Yeah.
It's a fucking amazing book.
It's Eh,
is it,
did you look it up?
Is it Victor Hugo?
You know victor,
I don't know.
I can't remember his name.
It's called man's search for meaning.
It's an old book.
That famous book.
It is a weird question when you try to figure out like what were,
what are you here for?
Like what is,
what is meaning,
you know,
if it is,
if you,
the human mind looks at the future and figures out that this is a certain amount
of time left is only a certain amount of time left.
If you're to believe that this world is real and all,
you really have a finite time as you,
if you believe this world is real.
It's funny you say that,
cause I,
I had lunch with my sister the other day who's very intelligent.
She's a partner in like the biggest law firm and we started talking about it and
we disagree on a lot.
Like,
she's actually,
she still believes in God and all this stuff.
And I said something about if you believe this world is real,
and she kind of gave the Descartes,
you know,
I think therefore I am.
And I'm like even how does he know?
He was fucking thinking.
You know,
like
how does he know when it becomes entirely more possible as technology increases
to envision a world some point in the future where it's going to be possible to
recreate reality in an indistinguishable form.
And it may have already happened.
We may be in it right now.
And then maybe one of the reasons why life is so ridiculous is because sometimes
like in a lot of movies,
there's some shitty writing.
And then this is a dude named wiener who likes to pull his dick out and show it
to girls on the Internet.
He just happens to be a senator,
you know,
or John Edwards,
he's what?
What?
Your wife's got cancer,
why don't you go fuck another chicken?
Should a load inside of her.
That'd be good for your presidential aspirations.
You,
I mean there's,
this is a real John Edwards,
not only that he's on trial right now,
but following his trial,
they want to put that guy in jail.
He almost became the president.
He was a real,
like,
he had a real good shot at being the vice president with [inaudible].
It look like the all American
piano.
He's a liberal,
he's an intelligent guy.
He's a lawyer,
he's fucking looks great.
But he fucked around.
But he was,
he was bagging this camera woman tripped over on its own deck and yeah,
and they're there.
Apparently what happened wasn't just that,
that's not why he's in trouble.
Why he's in trouble is because of his campaign finances.
He apparently use some of the money to finance her living and him hiding her.
So that's what he's,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
As has as scandalous or not scandalous,
but as corrupt as campaign financing is that they'll go after him.
Well,
I think they want to go and after a guy for stealing money from a drug dealer,
like right.
That's fun.
The money.
So shitty in campaign financing,
the way it's coming in and how illegal and how,
how all these corporations are financing campaigns.
It's the,
it's the fundamental problem with American.
You're right.
But in the,
in this instance,
one of the state,
one of the things about it is this to very specific wealthy donors that he had
courted.
And so it was really like he bribed them of my day yet he knew that his campaign
was going to fall apart because he knew that I was getting,
I understand,
but those fuckers are buying influence.
So that's what you get.
You,
you know,
you're maybe one of them was a wealthy individuals.
A woman.
Yeah.
But like if you saw the guy that was financing new to campaign or Santorum's
campaign,
these are just EGOMANIAC fucking rich people.
Super,
super,
super rich that,
that have done everything and it's on their bucket list.
And then they also have ideals like,
you know,
I think the world should be run like this.
So I'm going to put money in the pocket of a,
of a politician,
you know,
with these super pacs now and the way they,
they do it and they go,
they're buying influence politicians.
I just read a great book,
Lawrence Lessig,
a republic lost and I've felt this way for years cause I,
I traveled all over the world doing comedy in every country I went to,
everybody yelled at me about America,
like every single green room of every comedy club.
No matter where I went,
it was like I was the representative for America and everybody wanted to fucking
yell at me about my country.
And,
and there was a lot I see wrong with America ton,
but at a certain point I started snapping.
I'd be like,
fuck off,
fuck off.
Do you buy Coca Cola will cocacola pays for the politicians to get elected.
So stop drinking coke and then you can come bitch at me.
Like if you're putting money in the corporation's pockets,
your pain for these politicians and make the decisions people are born into a
system of,
they have no control of and to to blame us for what's going on with the military
industrial complex.
I have a joke,
my first album about it,
like English people saying you're responsible for this,
you're responsible for that.
Like country.
Well me,
I don't even vote I steel cable.
Okay,
you're not talking about me.
I'm just a dude who got shot,
you know,
shout out of a vagina some,
some odd years ago and here I am and now we're talking.
This is number responsible for this crazy fucking machine and I can't fix it
either.
I'm 24 years old.
Yeah,
okay,
go fuck yourself.
But there is a,
there's this,
that feeling when you go places and you feel like
I got it.
I ended up making a documentary film about it called America the punchline and
about how white everywhere I was going Comedians,
I'd be in Hong Kong,
I'd be in Dubai,
being South Africa,
they're all fucking making.
I always apologize,
apologize and say that I come to you from America.
I come to you from the balls of the dictus fuck in the world.
That's where I live
and that's a very common thing for Americans,
American comedians to apologize because it's that you have to,
you get there and there.
I used to go on stage in England,
like back around 2003 2004 I would walk on stage and they go to the next
comedians and American and I would do it for fun.
I'd tell him,
he'd go,
what do you want as your intro?
I'd go,
just say I'm American.
And they go to the next comedians.
American.
Ooh,
the whole crowd would boo.
Wow.
Before they saw my act,
I'm like,
now I'm used to it.
I have to.
I go on,
not,
not in.
So you did this on purpose and then would you go up and just,
I would do it.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
In the beginning I would apologize,
like when I first started going to England and all over the world,
I would apologize.
And then I got to the point where I'm like,
I knew where I could stand.
And I was like,
and I liked that.
I just wrote them in on it.
Like,
Oh,
you just booed me now.
Now,
now I'm able to come after you.
Because it was funny like I was,
I wasn't doing well over there when I would be like,
oh,
I'm sorry.
You know,
But when I'd be like,
really?
You know who,
who's our ally?
You know?
How are you pointing the finger at us when you're fucking right?
But even that,
I mean,
you're talking about we're really,
man,
you think AAA age doesn't work for the alliance deal?
I'll tell you what,
when you're talking nonsense,
I mean,
even saying that,
I don't know what the fuck they're doing.
Do you know what they're doing?
Who's allies?
What does that even mean?
What's evolved in this alliance where the lines,
cheese,
I just was watching yesterday,
they're saying Pakistan and Afghanistan are about,
they might go to war with,
well,
there was a theory that someone said to me,
Oh,
it was Duncan Duncan Trussell said there's a theory.
I believe he was quoting it,
but the what it was was that the idea is that as the world falls apart,
really it's your own reality that's falling apart.
It's just the reality of the world is that it's really a piece of your
imagination and that as the world gets more and more chaotic and we move closer
to the end of the Mayan calendar and there's nuclear wars,
a threatened about what all that really is Fukushima's meltdown the pollution in
the oceans.
It is really your own reality of your temporary existence in this plane is
coming to an end.
I believe that to sort of maybe,
I mean that's what we were talking about earlier when we're talking about like
whether or not life really is a work of fiction.
I mean,
I wouldn't say that I believe it,
but I don't not believe that.
That's what I said,
because I don't know what I know I've,
I've,
I mean I,
I get a lot of shit about these crazy,
what if scenarios where you stop and think about it and you're like,
what if this and what if,
what if this is a,
this is artificial,
but at a certain point in time,
we know that's going to happen.
If you look at like what you now what,
just look at this,
the fact that I can get on this laptop and I can just watch movies and I can
and,
and interact with people and exchange information and,
and the graphics are incredible and the photos are high definition.
This is just one step in a process that is not going to stop unless resources
run out.
And we all wind up being fucking zombies and cannibals.
I mean,
it was really the only way civilization is going to have to fall apart for us to
lose our obsession with the direction that technology is moving.
There's never gonna be a time when we go,
you know what?
We have enough technology.
We're cool with this.
Well we have to do is clean up our mess.
No,
but there also could be the chance of a solar flare or something that just wipes
it all out where then the earth starts over again like an ice age or something
where we start from ground one again where we start super possible and then you
and you think about if we evolve from or not if we have all,
but as we evolved from apes or were apes camp originally,
what they came from and that whole millions and millions of year process that
has to start all over again and they might not get like,
we don't even know it.
How do we even know if we have gotten the the furthest along?
You know,
it's really fucked up man.
When you look at those pictures of like what we evolved from,
you know,
I'll steal your pithy kiss and all these dudes that live like a million years
ago.
That's not that long ago.
It's amazing that it go from a million years to today and look how much
different,
we looked at every other ape like one ape started standing up,
and by the way,
there wasn't just one of us.
There was a gang of us,
different species,
a lot of them that never made it like the Flores,
the hobbit man that they found recently that has recently as I think it was
10,000 years ago,
they were living coinciding with human beings.
What's the hobbit?
The little hobbit people,
a little tiny people,
a tiny race of human beings on an island.
Are they are,
they may be like a complete set.
What's the wharves are today?
No,
no,
no.
There,
there are tiny people there.
They're in proportion.
A dwarf is,
the idea is that it's a genetic anomaly in their body of they have short arms
and a large head.
We had on talking shit my pockets with the other day we had a,
I think it's door.
No,
midgets would,
no,
you're not allowed to say that.
They explained it.
We had,
I had,
I had as our guests,
I had three dorms.
I know it was a dwarf it proportionate person who's very tiny.
No.
Which one is the proportionate?
It's rare.
So many different types of it that they were explaining all their types,
like a tenure,
Lee Davis and a nickname Nicky and Brad Williams were all in the show and they
were all explaining that they all had,
I think the three of them had three different types of dwarfism.
And then they talked about if they were to have sex and have a child,
like there's a 25% chance that it could acquire like that.
And they know all this because they go to like the little people of America
Convention,
which I went to this year,
which is fucking amazing.
Um,
and they,
they study all this stuff and they know like they've,
I think they've isolated the gene that causes it causes and
uh,
they know what it is and they threw like gene therapy and every,
not gene therapy or we'll,
you know,
whatever they do,
like stem cell or whatever,
they might be able to prevent it from happening in the future and reverse it.
No,
they can't reverse it,
but they might be able to prevent it from happening.
And I think a lot of doors were upset about this saying like,
you're going to kill our spaces.
Yeah.
It make them wrong.
So you're going to just modify the gene to make it like a sexy doors.
Cause I think if they did it right,
it would be cool.
Well,
I have a friend in Australia,
this guy,
he,
uh,
he Monae who is 41 pounds and he's full grown and he is the smallest manual
ever.
See.
And he's a standup comedian and he is fucking tiny.
And he is a thing,
I think it's called Rhema disorder if I'm,
if I'm right.
And the only other person in the world that has it,
it is his sister and her name's Rema.
And uh,
he just looks like a miniature person.
Everything's proportionate,
everything,
even his cock and uh,
no,
he claims it's big.
Jose.
He's a back pedal toughie.
I would say
he's t's,
he's about up to your thigh,
midway up your thigh.
And uh,
that's crazy.
I mean,
he's tiny.
He's a funny comedian.
Really funny.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
And I've gotten them wasted,
which is fun.
Like I,
I'm asking you to drink,
he had wine one wine cooler.
He smokes pot,
like of what I've seen like a fiend and drinks,
like I saw him one night,
probably have six gin and tonics and I was,
he's got long hair too,
which is funky.
And I had to hold his hair because he was puking and I ended up class.
I ended up carrying him about 20 blocks home,
like red,
like a baby.
Like I had to carry him in my arms
first.
I had them on budget,
like a sandbag.
Did you get them in a gable grip?
First item on my shoulder,
like a parrot.
Do you get them in the Guillotine group?
It's an odd group.
This to palm outward and the other one inward.
It's really good for kids,
teens.
And then,
and then I just took it back to my house and uh,
and I let him pass out on my couch because,
uh,
he was just so fucked up and he would add to get home.
And I was like,
you know,
you don't want like a stumbling door for walking around the street.
What is,
he technically is not a door frame.
He has this thing called Rhema disorder,
but what does what what I'm getting at,
they don't like the word [inaudible] the word midget,
but he used to be that there was like midgets and dwarves and there were two
different Midge Midge it comes from the word image or something,
which is an insect.
So you're calling them an insect and they also don't like it because their whole
lives,
they've been identified as look at the midget.
And so it's not like,
it's just seems so weird that the name change is going to change anything,
isn't it really?
The intent with you know mean I agree,
but I think,
I think it's like when you look at,
like when I said like cracker,
the word cracker doesn't hurt anyone.
Nobody's ever gone.
That upsets and I'm,
I'm one for like I say on stage,
I say absolutely every word I can possibly think of.
I have a joke about him.
I go,
my best friends is a,
is a midget,
he's a real life du Du du Lu and he hates the word midget.
He,
he says that's the most offensive thing you can call a little person.
And I'm like,
what about Nigger midget?
And that's a,
that's a lot more because it's not like your people are enslaved except in the
wizard of Oz.
But they like,
I understand where they're coming from that their whole life because I've been
with and I feel like you've got to just give it to them just because they've got
Delta shitty hand.
If that's going to make you happier that we won't say major that I won't say
man,
I've walked home,
I've walked down the street with them and it's amazing.
Like when you're with a black person,
people aren't pointing it this day and age,
yelling,
look at the n word,
but when you're with a little person,
people fucking point and yell.
Do you watch game of Thrones?
No.
Everyone's telling me I have to go one little dude who's on the,
I don't know his name.
I should probably look at the purpose.
Fucking brilliant.
And he steals the show that got shows.
God Damn is that the famous,
the famous little guy.
Dinklage Peter.
Just one,
something like that.
That he's really good.
Yeah,
he's a great actor.
He's the best actor in the show.
Well,
Nikki was on nick who was on our podcast the other night is in boardwalk empire.
He's the fighter.
Do you know Dick Nickname?
Vicky?
No,
I thought he said Lipnick he before,
like
he's,
he's kind of a midget,
isn't it?
Your buddy?
Yeah,
right buddy?
I don't want to park couch.
No.
John Headphones Buddy.
Oh yeah,
he chokes out front apparently.
You know,
I would do Jujitsu,
like I'm kind of with you on that,
that in a couple of other reasons,
but I would do Jujitsu if somebody like Rhonda Rozy,
uh,
it took like five other of the hottest girls and it was just like,
you have to choose one of these girls every day.
You get to choose kind of like,
you know,
like,
uh,
the bunny ranch and then you choose which one you want and it's Nogi and you,
they will teach you Jujitsu.
I would do it that way.
Teach you,
yeah,
but listen,
I've wrestled,
I wrestled women and if you're just training,
if they're just being,
teachers won't know.
No,
fuck it.
I wrestled two girls in a Jello.
I wrestled two girls in a jello wrestling contest for a radio promotion.
And uh,
I said to the girls beforehand,
I go,
hey,
and these weren't UFC girls.
They're just girls.
And I go,
Hey,
let's take it easy.
No one needs to get hurt here.
Like,
I know I can't be,
I can't fucking beat the shit out of them.
Everybody's,
and you're like,
you're an asshole.
So I know they're just going to club the shit out of me.
So I'm like,
I had watched during the Jello wrestling,
I was the only guy in it.
It was all chicks and me and the,
the round before me,
a chick,
the bottom of the,
uh,
it was like,
just like one of those inflatable pools,
right?
The bottom of the pool was just on cement.
So they're wrestling on,
on a piece of nylon over cement.
Oh,
Jesus.
And I watched this girl pick up a girl slammer and her hits the ground and I
hear
the girl goes,
oh,
I'm going to go broke my jaw.
And I'm like,
this is fucking,
and then I'm going in next and the girls are taunting me and they're going,
we're going to kick your ass is after you can watch it on you if you,
if you Google Eddie gift,
a Jello wrestling,
you can watch.
So the girls are fucking beating the fuck out of me.
Beating the fuck.
Like I had scratches and blood coming like,
and I'm going calm the fuck down.
Like,
this is a show,
not like,
and,
and they're gouging it,
me and all that.
So finally I just was like,
all right,
that's it.
So I thought,
what can I do?
I can't fucking hurt them.
So I just started like pulling off their,
their,
their bikini tops and bottoms.
And I was like,
at least that's where there'll become defensive.
So if I just start showing their titties to everybody,
you know,
I,
when I look like the good guy,
the crowd likes me and sure enough,
uh,
I accidentally fingered one of them.
I think
one of the chips you can watch,
I pick her up and body slammer and you just hear ago,
I broke my fucking nose.
You blood everywhere.
Body slammed her and she broke her nose.
They were beating the fuck out of me.
Oh Wow.
Oh my God,
Dude.
They're beating the shit out of you.
What is the name of this?
How to run youtube,
Eddie,
if a jello wrestling.
Oh my God,
dude,
they're trying to fuck you up.
So you weren't on the offensive,
you were just being defensive here.
Cause I gotta tell you,
I think I could take these two bitches.
Yeah.
What do you do?
Oh yeah,
you got her Bra.
No mouse.
You know what dude,
you tried to be gentlemanly even how you took off her bra.
Oh Shit.
Oh that bitch totally broke her nose and she's laughing about it.
And what a psycho.
Oh my God,
that checks a psych.
What,
what do you do in that situation?
I don't do that.
I wouldn't know.
I don't like,
I don't like me when I get mad.
You try to finger,
it's that sounded like the hulk.
He wouldn't like me when I'm angry.
I don't want to get a physical vehicle.
I don't want to ever put myself in a position where I'm physical with a check at
all like that.
Me Neither.
And I like in high school,
one time I had a girl,
I beat up her brother and uh,
luckily he's a fair fight kind of thing.
I beat him up.
We need a fist fight.
I won and she was older,
like two years older and she was like the biggest burnout,
fucking hardcore like crazy bitch in the school and everybody's like,
you're dead.
She came to get me and she beat me up in front of the whole high school.
Like she was just slapping me in the face and punched and I just had to sit
there and take it and I just sat there and just took every po like,
and just,
I just kept calling her a con.
There's a woman,
there's this woman who was a lesbian and she was also a like a really high level
taekwondo players.
She was,
she had fought in a lot of national tournament's placed.
She had been,
she was like,
she was very good.
And um,
she was a in the class and she had this hard on from men.
Like she would especially that weren't as good as her.
She would beat the fuck out of that.
She would be,
she'd beat the fuck out of Steve.
You know,
Steve Graham,
remember Steve,
my buddy Steve beat the fuck out of Steve.
And then I had to go with our next and the only reason why my instructor paired
me up with her was to punish her because she shouldn't have been going with me.
I was,
that was when I was like,
I was a US Open champion for time,
Massachusetts state champion.
It was a man and I was just a lot faster and stronger than us and bigger and she
fucking attacked me.
She screamed like it was sparring.
Okay,
this is not a fight.
This is sparring and she screamed and just charged at me and I put a whooping on
this bitch.
I don't,
I never usually beat girls up,
but I put a beat on that girl.
I didn't hit her,
I didn't hit her in her face.
I only hit her in her body and but I clowned her.
I would like oh do things to her that I knew she couldn't do to me.
I like double kicker would kick with my left foot and the kick or my rifle at
the same time about to stand right in front.
I just did a bunch of shit that she couldn't do to me because you're at such a
disadvantage.
Like I've always thought I'm,
yeah it was,
it was all a,
yeah,
cause like I've seen that work.
Girls want to enter like that kind of sport and I'm all for women playing
sports.
If you're,
if you're an equal that's fine.
But in a sport like this that there's a cultural exchange there that makes it
like,
like football.
You know,
when a girl wants to play football,
you know,
how do you feel about him?
Like a god,
it's going to get,
it's like girls in the military.
Well let me explain it to you.
When it comes to martial arts,
it's real simple.
You don't take advantage of anybody that's below you.
You,
you try to be as nice as possible to the underclass when you don't,
I mean occasionally when you're sparring,
especially with the contact,
like kicking and punching,
someone gets knocked out and,
but you don't ever try to knock out someone who's a lower ranked than you.
You always try to control yourself.
Sit Happen.
Sometimes people running things or you catch someone funny and it just,
you didn't know you're gonna knock 'em out and they go unconscious.
That would happen,
but you should never do it on purpose.
And when someone who's a black belt,
like this woman was went after this guy who had like fucking 20 knee surgeries
can't move that good and he's not,
you know,
he's only a green belt to just start off.
And she went and attacked him like it was a god Damn Street fight.
It was.
There's a,
there's a level of aggression that people sometimes will take out on people in
sparring.
The only reason they do it is because they can,
it's just bullying.
That's all it is.
It's straight bullying.
She would go after guys and beat the shit out of him,
but I see her spar women,
nothing like that.
Man.
When she would spar women,
she would take it easy on them.
She would,
she would pull her punches and kicks.
She was trying to knock guys out.
There was a,
there was a real aggression to what she charged after me may like screamed at
me.
I was like 19 and when I was 19 I was,
I was half crazy and I was not taking it from some bitch.
I put a beating on this check.
I stomped her in the chest.
I remember like not not knowing how to hit her so that it was more of a push
than a kick,
but just to let her know what's up.
Launched her to the air and she's skid on her butt.
And then I chased her down and they stood over
and then I let her get back up and then I just started beating on her.
I'll never forget this because I was,
it was a real moment in my life where I said,
I am not going to hurt her.
I am not going to hurt her because my instincts were to knock on unconscious.
My instincts were to kick her in the face.
I was like,
I'm gonna kick this pitch in the face,
but I can't.
I,
there's like,
there's no way you can do that.
So it was a,
it was a,
it was a battle because I was in a fight with a woman because if it was a guy
and he took advantage of another guy like that,
you would,
that's your thought is I'm going to knock this guy out.
I'm gonna kick him in the face.
He deserves this.
But then you go,
I have to make a concession here because this is a woman.
So he said,
you have to like,
I mean,
there were,
there were times in the gym where it just became all out fights and,
uh,
luck.
There was two times that I could really remember one of them.
Unfortunately,
it was when we had concrete floors,
we only had office carpeting over concrete floors,
and we would spar full contact.
This is no bullshit.
And this was a hardcore fucking school.
We would fight in these,
these taekwondo tournament,
and they were scary.
But the training was scarier than the fucking fights because at least the f the
training,
you know,
would,
you would be with your friends.
It sounds like fight club,
you know,
all their shit and they're all preparing and you're gonna have to find a four or
five,
six times when you're fighting,
you're probably going to find someone who's not as good as your training
partners and you're not going to have to fight as many times.
You know,
it's like it was way easier,
but like new guys would come in all the time and it would wind up being just a
brawl.
That's all it was.
It'd been,
I can't remember how many times we had to drive people to the hospital after we
fucked them up.
Cause we would get in these situations where a guy would come in from another
school and a year usually weren't that good,
you know,
and they would get,
they would get cocky or insulin and then the instructor would let them go join
class.
Like,
go ahead,
put your club.
Would you like to join our class?
We can have the first class for free.
And we know we were just supposed to beat the fuck out of this guy.
So it was like,
it was completely irresponsible.
But that's how it was handled when anybody was a Adeline and they came to the
school,
he wound up being a street fight and Hong Kong Crete.
It was a thin office carpet on concrete.
So this is how I essentially grew up from age 15 to 21.
That's all I did.
So when some chick is screaming at me,
chasing after me,
like she's going to like attack me after I watched her just beat up my friend,
you know,
there was,
that was not happening,
but it was,
it was a milestone for me where I was able to not hurt her.
You know,
it was like very important.
So it was like 20 pounds heavier than I was.
Totally unfair,
but I was able to not hurt her.
Very important.
Well,
I was,
uh,
I don't know if it was the night we did your show,
but,
uh,
I was at a comedy club one night,
and afterwards there was a,
there was an argument I was,
I had headlined there or something.
There was an argument about buying drinks or something,
and a couple of argued with a waitress and the,
the women were fighting the,
the,
the girl that didn't want to pay our bill was arguing with the waitress at the
comedy club and they were screaming,
yelling at each other.
It pours out kind of into the street.
And
the,
uh,
waiter stands up for the waitress.
This black dude standing up for the waitress going,
hey,
you know,
you need to back off,
blah,
blah.
And so then her husband gets in.
So it's the black guy and the husband who's a Mexican date,
so black guy,
Mexican dude,
and the Mexican guy's wife is standing behind them and they're arguing and
they're about the,
it's escalating into a fight.
And you can tell the Mexican dude does not want to fight,
but he's,
he standing his ground,
but he doesn't want to fight.
You know,
when two guys are going in,
the black dudes like,
Yo,
get the fuck outta here.
You know,
you pay your bill,
get the fuck out,
blah,
and the Meccan fuck you.
Fuck you.
A lot of fuck yous,
you know,
in a fight to escalate.
But you can tell,
no one really wants to fight.
He's wife comes over to the shoulder and punches the black dude from the comedy
club that works there.
Oh No.
And I see the whole thing and I thought to myself,
I've never an and an what I thought should have happened right there is the
black dude and the Mexican dude should a high fived and
the Shit Outta his wife.
Like she,
cause she just got two guys in a fight who like one guy didn't want to find him,
probably was going to get his ass character.
Yeah.
Her husband didn't want to fight.
The black,
didn't just wanting to break up and now she's got now there,
they have to fight each other,
which they did.
And by the way,
the black dude got a good punch in on her really because she hit on me.
He hit her right back.
He hit both of them as he should copy craziness.
Cops show up and they're like,
what happened?
I'm like,
take her,
take her.
There's your,
I had an ex girlfriends or a swing at me that's assault.
If you ever had an ex girlfriend.
Oh yeah.
I've had a couple of,
that's the darkest moment ever.
When you really,
oh my God,
someone is fucking punching me.
A girl punched me on set once to just didn't quite catch me.
I put my hand up just in time.
I was doing this show.
It was for Merv Griffin and um,
uh,
it was a law show,
like a,
like a courtroom show.
We were going to call it like Rogan's law.
It was like,
I wasn't really a judge,
but I would like decide your cases.
It's been done since then again.
I think Paul Mooney did it.
No,
no.
I rarely does it.
Comedy quarter.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then someone else did it too.
There was another one,
I don't remember who the other comic was too.
But anyway,
the,
so it's a funny idea.
It could have been fun,
but they had a bailiff or whatever.
It was a court reporter,
the court reporter,
and she was this chick professional hot check,
a little worn out,
little weathered,
you know,
not a bad girl but was partying fucking hard.
I mean just red lining it.
And she was one of those girls that would come over and she would flirt with all
the writers.
And I mean this is like,
she hadn't really done anything yet.
She had a star on her back and I go,
why do you have a star?
She'll self fulfilling prophecy.
She actually said that,
which is,
that's how I mean you say whoa man.
But that's all a lot of actors think.
And I tell you before I had children,
I looked at it completely differently cause I used to look at it and go through
this fucking crazy bitch fucking self fulfilling prophecy.
I would go agro with it,
right?
Yeah.
But now I look at it and I see a little kid that was just raised all fucked up.
You know,
she was only like 29 or 30 years old or something like that.
And she looked like she was closing in on 40.
She looked 10 years older than her age and she was just hitting it hard.
And two,
I probably was a great girl.
She probably wasn't batches they all need love or something.
They're all broken and damaged on little children that just didn't get enough
attention.
They should change the Hollywood sign to daddy didn't love me.
Yeah,
it's true.
That's my problem.
So,
um,
anyway,
she,
she goes out the night before we have to film and uh,
I don't know if she's nervous because this is like a,
you know,
this is like the first thing that she's ever done,
this pilot and she gets coke,
does it to the gills.
She stays up all night and she shows up in the morning to film with no sleep,
no sleep and crashing hard,
crashing hard and going full psycho mode.
And you know,
I'm the one who's got to take these cases.
So they tell me,
um,
what the subject of each cases,
right?
I before I meet the people and they actually come up with the case.
I sit down with a notepad and I started going,
okay,
these are real problems.
These people are like real issues.
It's like,
you know,
I have to really figure out what this is and what's funny about it and I'm
trying to make it so some sitting there writing,
it's like,
Oh God,
I'm so tense,
Joe,
can you give me a massage?
Can you give me [inaudible]?
I go,
you don't even have to do anything,
are you?
You're just sitting there.
I go,
you don't have to worry about it.
don't be tense.
I go,
I have to write all this stuff down.
I have to,
I have to ad Lib.
I go,
we only,
we're going to film in like two hours.
I really can't
you fucking asshole you fucking house all.
I just asked you to be nice.
I just asked you to read.
Now it's like I'm fucking nervous and I am,
and it was just complete 100% psycho.
Yeah.
She just did not have any connection with reality.
There was no rational response to the way the conversation was going,
you know,
you should like if someone says,
can I have a massage?
You know,
and then you tell them that you're working,
they should be like,
oh,
okay,
sorry,
what am I doing?
Asking you for a massage.
You know,
laugh about it.
Like silly me,
I'm,
you're the one that needs,
I'll get somebody else to rub my back.
Don't worry about it.
But it was like this weird thing where she wanted attention.
She wanted like sexual attention.
She wanted to be attractive.
She wanted someone to,
uh,
to dote on her so that she would feel better.
But she was just whacked out from the coke or whatever the fuck she was doing
math or whenever it was.
But she was clearly up all night and she was with her friend and her friend just
had these,
these,
this thousand yard stare,
this just lost look in her eye.
Like,
you know,
like these bitches had just been to nom and came back with their shoes and their
hands barefoot walking to the parking lot,
looking at it,
take a hooker bath.
And the dressing room sink and I'm not bullshitting.
So she's like throwing makeup on.
But she's super frustrating cause she's got heavy bags under her eyes.
She's just gacked out of her head.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
they wound up using a girl who was an extra,
they fired her.
She took a swing at me.
That's what I didn't get to the point.
And when you no,
I said,
well,
I was like,
what are you talking about?
I go,
you're acting crazy.
we're,
we're about to film this thing.
I go,
why do you,
why are you demanding so much attention from me?
I go,
please.
And she fucking just hauled back.
And I'm like,
no,
this bitch is not hitting me right now.
And I'm like halfway.
And I'm like,
Dude,
you better get your fucking hand off.
She's going to hit you in the face.
Full swing.
Yeah.
She,
she took a swing at me,
man.
And I caught it like last one.
I was like,
oh my God,
you're hitting me.
Really?
I don't understand that because that's,
that's fucking a salt.
Yeah,
that's what I said to her.
Which way to,
or even more,
I go,
excuse me,
that's illegal.
I go,
that's a assault.
You can go to jail for that.
You shouldn't be hitting people.
You know?
Look man,
a man should certainly not hit a woman by,
by any stretch of the imagination.
And then she,
exactly.
And men shouldn't hit men,
but women,
you're,
you're hitting a man.
You're crazy.
That's like if I went over and punched a monkey or a gorilla or something like
that,
the thing that kill you,
what are you doing?
You're going to hit a man.
Somebody,
I just saw something that somebody said,
those bumper stickers,
there's never an excuse for a man to hit a woman.
And it's like there's never an excuse for anyone to hit anyone.
Yeah,
exactly.
Unless it's self defense.
Unless you're trying to save your life or your consciousness or,
or stop someone from beating somebody else up.
But yeah,
I mean,
I had a girlfriend,
her doing that to a girl doing that.
To me,
it's like me going up to Alistair Overeem and punching him.
I'd want to do that.
He's going to fucking kill me.
I had a girlfriend punch me while I was in bed sleeping.
Oh my
drives.
I tagged.
I didn't pay for it though.
Brian's all like whatever,
whatever.
I woke up with this just wailing on me.
Yeah,
that's kind of what mine was.
I kicked the girl like I,
she was living with me.
I kicked her out.
I was like,
she was just,
she was like out all night doing coke and not coming home and shit like that and
I go,
just fucking move.
Just get your shit out.
So I come home one night and her dog has shit all over my house,
like everywhere I go.
And she was supposed to be home and she just stayed out all night.
Like I was out.
I come back and her dog shit all over my house and she didn't like,
and I go,
that's it.
That's it.
And she was up,
she was hot.
She was super hot.
She was a stripper.
And if my fault,
I know,
you know,
like you know what he's talking about.
It sounds perfect.
I know that.
I mean,
everything sounds like it's in place.
Yeah.
But like we've got it all when you were,
when you,
when your data's stripper,
it's like doing heroin the first time.
It's like,
all this is fucking amazing.
And then the next time and your friends are all shaking your head did,
you don't want to do this.
It always ends up ugly.
And you're like,
no,
this is,
this one's different.
This one's different.
So I've dated strippers,
it turned out to be very nice girls.
But I saw,
and I'm friends with some girls that are dancers,
but this one was fucking the psycho she has,
there are a lot of schools out there.
So I go,
I go,
you gotta,
you gotta go,
you gotta get out.
I called her on the front.
I go and put in your shit outside my house and,
and just come and get it and go.
She doesn't have a lot of stuff.
I was like,
just come get your stuff and go somewhere and go,
oh,
that's what you fucked up because you,
you made her come to you.
You should never do that.
We were supposed to do is have it brought to her by the blackest dude,
you know,
and I didn't realize the biggest,
yeah.
I not scared,
whatever,
you know,
it's,
if you don't get a black Samoan,
we'll do angry looking Simone,
hopefully with some fucking visible tattoos near his neck.
I,
I came home and I was just like,
fuck the dog and shit.
I was so mad.
I was like,
but I didn't do it.
I didn't put her stuff outside,
but she came home and raged and I'm just in bed sleeping and she just starts
wailing on me.
What the fuck?
She goes,
you're lucky.
I almost called the cops and told them you had a gun.
And I'm like,
they would have taken me to jail like w how crazy are you?
And a funny thing is I broke up with her since then and,
uh,
like years ago.
And uh,
I just googled her to see what's going on.
The only thing I could find,
he said she was arrested for assault.
I'm like some other dude.
Got It.
Yeah.
Well,
some people grow up thinking it's okay to hit people,
you know what I mean?
Especially like in the household,
if they see their mom and her dad beating each other up,
they grow up in that environment and they think that that's how relationships
are.
You get mad at someone,
you lash out at them like a child.
I have one girlfriend do it,
but she didn't really do it.
She kind of halfheartedly did it.
She just is mad at me and she was young and we were both young and she was like
20 I was like 21 she sorta took a swing at him.
He kinda ducked under it.
I had a girl,
I had a girl kick me.
I think the only time I,
I've,
I think I've called a girl a contar face like a couple times in my life in New
York.
I'm getting a taxi was not living unless you have too many to count.
I said to their face,
oh really?
That doesn't mean anything.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
I'm standing on the street in New York City.
It's five in the morning.
I've just come out of a bar.
I've been drinking all night and I hail a cab and you know how like sometimes
you'll be standing there and somebody else has been waiting longer than you,
but they're down the street a bit.
I'm waiting.
I held his cab and it stops for me.
So I opened the door but she sees it stopped for me and she's been waiting.
She comes running up the street to where I am and she's like screaming.
So I like stop and look and she pulls back and she's got on those fucking New
York City,
fuck me boots.
You know that they all wear the black leather high,
you know,
like,
like knee high boots.
She pulls back and kicked me in the Shin as hard as she can and it felt like a
chip on my bone came out of my Shin and I just looked at her and I wait,
you [inaudible] and as [inaudible] was coming out,
I,
it didn't even get to fully come out cause her,
her right fucking hook hit me right in the face.
Like she punched me as I said,
God.
And I'm like,
you fucking psycho.
And I was so angry that I did not know what to do.
I look at her boyfriend and I go and I look at her and I go,
and I had like a bunch of dudes with me too.
I go,
I'm going to beat the fuck out of him right now.
He's going to die because you did that.
I'm like,
I'm going to fucking kill him.
you're fucking dead,
dude.
You're
fucking dead.
And,
and he just grabbed her.
He goes,
come on,
let's go,
let's go.
Because I couldn't like do anything to her.
I should add or a rescue palm struggler right.
And then those
open hand,
like this map,
just a good gorilla slap.
The nose goes bad.
And you know,
I've have these conversations before with people and there's,
there's some people that have this really black and white thing with women.
Like you cannot ever hit women,
which is crazy.
A women will stab you.
[inaudible] a woman will kill you.
I,
I know a dude who got killed by his wife.
Okay.
Don't tell me you should cause guess what?
If a woman pulls a gun on,
you should punch her in the face.
If you can't,
it's the way to save your life to say that you shouldn't.
Oh,
of course you shouldn't go out of your way to do it.
And you know,
and when I say that,
I've called a lot of women constants cause I've lived motherfucker,
okay.
I've been a God standup comedian working in bars for 23 years.
You don't think I ever run across a few days and count on stage melamine for
some,
for some people,
you know,
like I get accused sometimes of being a misogynist because I'm just honest about
it.
But no one loves women more than me.
My house is filled with women.
My daughters are all women.
I have women everywhere.
I mean I wrote a girl cat.
I love women.
I just don't,
I just don't like I do girls ever.
My house has half pink,
but I don't like cons.
I love,
I love women,
I love Nice people.
I love Nice men.
I don't like Douche bag.
But it's a weird thing and we've brought it up before,
but it bears noting and re repeating.
Why is it that if you have a problem with guys,
nobody ever says you hate men.
Yeah,
there's not even a,
there is a word for it.
Because I brought this up once.
I said,
there's no word.
I tried to write a joke about it.
I said,
you know,
there's a word for hating women saw,
but there's no word for hating men other than lesbian.
And uh,
and like somebody,
there is a word,
whatever the word is,
nobody knows it.
But the important thing is it's not respected.
It's a weird thing.
It's like when women are allowed to,
uh,
you're,
you're allowed to say things like that.
[inaudible] week dude's are allowed to say things to when a guy says,
you hate women,
God damn it,
that it's one of my pet peeves.
Like,
you fucking pussy.
You goddamn trader.
What team are you want?
A guy gets in an argument with a con and you're like,
Ooh,
I've,
I've seen it happen man.
There was a guy who did it to me once.
We were at a club.
Okay,
this is bad.
And this is after a friend of mine had killed his best friend in a drunk driving
accident when I was in high school.
I don't want to say his name,
Tim.
Uh,
he,
uh,
lived right down the street from me.
He killed his buddy in a drunk driving accident.
It was devastating.
And I remember,
I'll never forget,
Tim and I,
we lived in the same neighborhood and I was walking down the street and it was
like a couple of weeks after it happened,
he still had the marks all over his face.
He was walking up the street.
I was walking down the street.
I looked at him and I said,
oh,
I said,
what's up to him?
He goes,
and he just walked past me and I,
I,
the fucking palpable feeling of sadness and regret and shame and horror.
And the story was he was drunk and he crashed his car and the cops were standing
over him when he woke up in the hospital
and he said,
the cop said something,
something like,
congratulations.
And he goes,
what?
What?
He goes and regulations that you killed your friend,
you're,
you're a fucking murderer because you were drunk and he killed your friend.
So he tried to jump out the window and they grabbed him and stopped him from
trunk jumping out the window.
So it was,
this was right after this happened.
Okay,
I'm doing standup and I'm on Martha's vineyard and there's people,
not Martha Sweet Cape Cod and people down the Cape would get food.
Good.
And it was me and a couple
other dudes and I'm,
one of them was this guy who was not a very funny guy,
but he was like one of those guys.
It was always trying to be like,
he is always trying to pick women's sides on everything.
It was like,
it was not,
it was a guy,
he was like super captain,
left wing liberal.
Right.
And these girls are,
I'm hackle on the show and they're hammered,
they're fucking hammered and we're outside and um,
uh,
we're,
we've,
we've done our gig.
That gig was a hell Gig,
you know,
it was terrible.
There was a hockey game going on in the refuse to turn the game off.
Instead they just turn the volume down.
So the hockey games on it
people every couple of months.
Oh,
they would yell for the hockey game.
It was just one of those gigs that you had
do when you were young.
These girls were outside and they are about to get in their car and they're
fucking slosh.
And I am so angry.
I'm so angry.
Cause I'm just thinking about my friend Timmy walking up the street and I'm
like,
what the fuck?
And I go,
dude,
these fucking drunk pigs.
I go,
it's not,
it's not bad enough that you've got a heckle at a comedy show and scream and
yell and ruin everybody's night now you're going to go drunk,
drive you fucking pig.
You know?
And they were just fat slopping gross and just mutants and,
and this guy turns to me,
he goes,
hey man,
I don't appreciate you talking about women like that.
I go,
I'm not talking about all women.
You'd dump.
Fuck yeah.
And these drunk pigs.
I go,
if those were guys,
would I be allowed to captain vagina and be,
I'd be allowed to call them pigs the fuck.
Of course I would.
Yeah.
These are cut humans.
These are human.
If I get five guys walking down the street and Klu Klux Klan outfits,
you know you're allowed to.
He like,
he like confronted me with it.
Like I really don't appreciate you talking about women like that.
Yeah,
I've been in that argument in Boston.
Have a lot of that man.
There was a lot of like,
I always feel that's,
there's that guy,
that type of guy that tries to get laid.
He can't get laid.
That's the problem.
But that's his,
that's his thing and he thinks that's his angle into it and it's so,
he's just as bad as anyone.
Like it's his it.
It's fucked up.
Yeah,
but I said what I said earlier,
it's really true.
A Garden and tells you that is a trader.
That's what he is.
He's selling out as gender for a couple of Brownie points with women so he could
be close to them.
Mrs,
can I sit by the fire?
You've been such a good boy.
Sit by the fire.
Thank you my love.
Thank you.
He just wants to be close and get scraps from the table.
That's a guy who never gorilla fucked a girl.
He's never ripped a girls' panties off or stuffed or under the corner of a couch
and sweat.
Honor when you're fucking her so hard,
you're dripping sweat off your chest under a face.
My contacts and my chest hair.
Then she puts her hands
through it and just,
you got to get some furious fucking going on to achieve those kind of levels of,
of cool,
off sweat,
whatever.
Some dude's just,
they,
they're born in this,
this crazy life with a weak hand.
Everything's week.
Their parents are weak.
Their genetics are weak,
their situations week or out,
it looks weak.
Their characters week,
their discipline is weak.
They don't accomplish what they want.
They don't have the courage to go after.
They want what they want to achieve.
That I'd ever become the man they wish they could be.
So all they do along the way is try to define the boundaries for everybody else
and tell everybody else how they should think it should not behave.
And the guys that they hide behind unfortunately is a good one.
The guys that you should be a nice person.
It shouldn't be an asshole.
Hates women.
I mean,
I've had,
I've been around people that hate women.
It's an ugly,
ugly thing when you hate all women.
That's a really gross thing.
I don't like that at all.
We've got a lot of those fans on our podcast that you do.
Oh and hey has the most,
they're the,
when they used to have this fucking hater shows where they would do these
comments,
so they booed dom Irrera in Philadelphia.
I've seen that.
That's the famous one where bill burr went out and shit on Philadelphia for like
10 minutes fast.
It's one of the greatest comedy performances of all.
It really is and it keeps going back to the time,
seven minutes,
and I'm doing all my time.
The best line is when he makes fun of the flyers,
the Philadelphia flyers for wearing slacks.
How build the best line is,
fuck you and fuck the liberty.
Oh,
that's funny.
Glasses.
I've had those,
those shows where it's gone that wrong and you're like,
no.
Like none of them have ever been close to as good as bill birds.
Like what he did up there,
because mine by ramp will last two a minute maybe.
You know,
I hate all of you.
I hope the fucking,
I hope the fucking ceiling collapses.
Like where the Indiana state fair.
You know I've,
I've set it up,
but that's a dated reference on Jab.
Nobody remembers.
He kept going and going and going and going and it was like,
and he was pulling out every reference,
every Philadelphia think the bridge and the rocky.
He goes,
you've got real world champions.
You're like,
Joe Frazier,
who you worship a fake guy from a fucking movie.
So fucking amazing.
He killed it.
I can't leave with how often comedians snap.
There's not more videos of the solo videos or snaps.
Man,
there's a lot.
This is a gang,
a heckler videos from me,
man.
There's one firm from last time I was up in Edmonton.
There's a,
the river Cree,
there's one,
there's some,
some check.
She wouldn't sit down.
I think I fucked with her for 20 minutes.
It was ridiculous.
Where are you playing in a theater up there.
Where you at?
Cherry Creek Casino.
Yeah,
that place is great.
That's funny.
They do fights up there a lot too.
It was a lot of MMA fans.
They have the MFC is up there.
I've been to Edmonton a couple of times.
They have these crazy shows they'd take like,
you know,
pretty high level talent like a lot of those guys come up through there and wind
up being UFC guys,
you know,
high level guys.
So they have like a good base of mixed arts fan up there
too.
And this plus China gotten into MMA at all?
Yes.
They're getting into it now because uh,
the dude,
the weight lifter,
Sean Waxman,
who was telling us how China is a,
he's like,
just wait til they get into crossfit because he said,
you know,
Olympic weightlifting is massive there.
He was claiming the Olympic weightlifting is like second to a soccer around the
world as a sport.
And it's just not recognized really in America.
It's not a big sport in America and around the world.
It's massive.
Like in Russia and China,
China will,
there's 2 billion people in China and it's a fucking massive sport in China and
he's like,
just wait till these fuckers get into crossfit.
He's like,
just wait cause they're there and it's all,
I was thinking the same thing with MMA.
I mean are they,
do they have a history because,
because China also,
the way they,
they put money into a sport and they like pull you out of your life.
You know,
it's Kinda like Russia used to and they're like,
you are going to be a javelin thrower.
That's what you're going to do for the rest of you.
You are going to be known as a javelin thrower.
Like if,
if they start doing the same kind of thing with MMA where it's like they're
taking young kids that look like they have the size to build the speed,
everything and going,
all right,
you know,
here we go.
Have time to train you.
That doesn't always work though.
Really.
The funny thing is it's like giving someone welfare.
A lot of times you got to have the drive yourself.
Yeah.
You got it.
Sometimes the,
the guys who make it through like having shitty jobs and getting to the top
though.
So like Anderson Silva worked at Mcdonald's.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's something about that,
you know,
Jon Jones was a bouncer with a,
a young girlfriend who with a child,
you know.
You know what I'm saying?
That's why that dude like gutted it up and became warrior.
Yeah.
But it's true.
I mean that's the real story.
John has two children and that's what he would,
that's why he dropped out of it
college.
He was going to wrestle for Iowa.
Yeah,
but,
but if,
if you gave them like more of a,
uh,
like a foundation as a young kid,
let's say they had it as a kid and they weren't,
they weren't pushed into it,
but they were doing it a lot younger at w what age do kids start?
Like a damage?
It too.
Some of them start really young.
Some stuff,
four or five really.
Somebody told me it's not good to have a kid do it cause they don't have the uh,
the cognitive,
a two year olds and my four year old choke each other.
I teach them that chose each other.
I teach them how to tap out cause they knew.
They naturally start wrestling on the yeah.
So while the rest of them on the bed,
I teach them what this is I control and this is how you get out of the guard.
You don't want to be here because he or she can control you.
I teach them really young so this is a part of their,
their way,
their body's moving.
Like what if you see my two year old and my four year old,
they have Jiu Jitsu matches my two year old Mount Sir and my four year old hip
escapes and she'll pull guard.
It's fucking pretty wild to see.
But it's just from showing them little natural moves.
I don't teach them how to finish each other but they do anyway.
They choke each other.
Especially the two year old,
the two year old,
she favors a fade or a million encode style rear naked choke where she grips
like this and pulls it across the trake.
She likes to trick,
choke you.
She doesn't go for like the Jujitsu leverage.
Once she,
she goes for a real nasty catch lock sort of choke
is cats.
They just,
it's natural.
It's natural.
The kids roll around and play together and teach them how to get into better
positions.
That's another reason I wouldn't do Jujitsu.
I,
I used to when I was a kid,
when guys would like wrestle in the pool.
I hated that because I always had this like fear,
like I surf a lot and when I get hold downs it makes me go fucking like,
I gotta go sit.
What do you think about that guy that got killed recently in South Africa?
Oh yeah.
I've surfed down there.
You ever Seen Sharks while you're surfing?
The other day I was surfing and I went to a duck dive under a wave.
It was,
and it was about four to six feet or something.
I go to duck dive and you ducked out,
you dip your board below you so it doesn't,
the wave doesn't catch it and then you go kind of under the wave and the waves
coming up on me in the face of the wave and I just see a fucking giant fish
shoot across in front of me.
So it's like pulling away from me and all I can do is rather than like continue
my duck dive,
which would have been probably the smartest thing to do,
I lifted like back then,
thus like throwing me into a back flip like the board May,
Oh my God,
like board first,
then my legs back over,
boom,
boom.
Like getting held down.
You know what is a duck dive?
You pushed the board under the nose of the board under the wave and so that the
wave goes over you and doesn't take you with it.
You actually don't take the force of the wave and you get through the wave and
you end up on the other side.
This is on your paddle out.
Oh,
I see,
I see.
So as I'm about to duck dive through it on the face of the wave,
I see the fish go,
how big,
how many feet?
It must've been like four or five feet and I went away from you or long long.
And I just went ah,
and went backwards and flip.
Then as I'm getting tumbled in the Whitewater and going through the wash,
I'm like fuck,
like I'm,
I'm getting held down so no breath.
And I'm like fuck,
trying to get to the surface so I can start swimming as fast as I can.
And uh,
I pull up and I looked back to see if I see a fin or something and it's a seal
and it's like,
it's like laughing at me.
I caught a seal once accidentally.
Oh,
I cut the line when I saw was a CEO.
We're were fishing and uh,
we were,
I forgot what we're trying to catch when we were fishing with bait also on the
line poles.
Big giant fish.
Yeah.
That's fucking big.
Yeah,
it's a seal.
But I've seen a of sucks though.
You feel like shit,
it'd be terrible to sketch burger king.
What is it as a seal or a sea lion?
What do they see?
Lines or see,
I think there are two different things.
The things that you see off of California,
right?
Aren't they see sea lions?
Yeah.
No,
but I think what I saw the other day was a seal.
I'm pretty sure it was a seal.
You know what's really fucked up,
man?
Those leopard seals.
Have you ever seen those things?
See Leopard sharks all the time?
Yeah.
Leopard seal is like,
it doesn't seem like a real animal.
Leopard seal seems like something from Star Wars.
It's a seal that's super predatory and as giant teeth and it's fucking hugely,
yeah,
it was in that movie,
happy feet.
It was like the,
uh,
the enemy in the movie.
Happy feet.
And that's how I found out about it.
Real.
Yeah.
No.
Or it was,
it,
was it happy feeder was,
no,
it was the actual march of the penguins.
It was actually march of the penguins because,
uh,
that's,
that's their,
their main enemy.
That's what leopard seals eat.
Penguins.
That's like their main food.
They're so scary.
They kill people.
They've killed people that they recently killed a photographer,
someone that got attacked and mauled.
Yeah.
There's all kinds of things.
I've got clients or photography,
lazy stories of a Dolphin.
I've seen a,
have you ever seen a leopard seal?
Now?
I've never told him.
Pull up a photo man.
It's Kinda,
it's kind of freaky.
I had the shark alarm went off on me in Bondai Australia.
What's,
what does that mean?
I'm surfing and all of a sudden I hear
and I'm like,
what?
And I just start looking around and every surfer's paddling out of the water.
And so my heart started beating.
I start paddling as fast as I can,
and I'm thinking it's probably a regular current.
I've surfed in Australia probably a hundred times.
I'm,
I'm like,
I've never heard of shark alarm,
but maybe this is a common thing on a crowded beach.
So I started paddling.
I look over at the guy next to me and I go,
uh,
and just to see what his reaction is.
And he goes,
he goes,
oh my God,
that's so scary.
That doesn't even look real.
Yeah,
that does look scary.
The one of them click on the one with the big mouth because most people can't
see what the fuck that is.
Yeah,
that one in the center.
That does look scary.
Looking at those fucking teeth,
that shit is ridiculous.
It doesn't seem like a real animal.
That's what's weird about it.
It seems like some something that someone invented in a movie.
Well a seal that the,
the uh,
the alarms going off.
I look at this dude and I go,
uh,
I look at him and he goes,
haven't heard that in a long time.
So I just start paddling.
It was like when you think you'd like fly out of the water,
it just seemed like an eternity,
I'm sure.
And then I got out and they said somebody,
somebody called and said they spotted like a four foot shark or something and
they have to get you out of the water.
But they're out there.
Like I've pictures a guy that owns horizon surf shop in Santa Monica,
took pictures in sunset,
the end where sunset comes out to the PCH,
a fucking giant,
great white breaching right there.
Oh my God.
And My iPhone.
I'll show you.
Please show it to me and I've gone down where that guy died last week.
That's in Cape Town.
I've gone there.
I went down in the cage with the great whites and saw them.
I would never surf there.
I know it's crazy.
There's only like five deaths a year worldwide from sharks and three of them are
there.
South Africa's fucking,
they're all over the,
they happen here to the Santa Barbara Guy got killed just two years ago.
Even seriously five people a year.
I mean more people died by dogs in California here,
but you know what?
You don't think how few people are in the fucking ocean tiny number and you look
at it.
If the whole world was in the ocean,
God dammit dude,
it would be a thousand deaths if you can find it.
Some guy,
they talked about your odds.
It's like one in 7 million are worth 700 billion of attacked by sharp.
Some guy did the odds then like he said,
if you're wearing a wetsuit,
okay,
you look more like a seal.
If you're on a surfboard,
it looks more like a fish.
So if you're by a river mouth where there they go to feed,
you're increasing your chances.
If you're alone,
you're increasing your,
he does the odds and increases a cha and it's,
it's fucking not,
it's like one in 10,000 La,
one in like 5,000 and this guy met.
So like I surf every,
but like I've gone through logical man,
whoever you are it where they go,
this place is Sharkey.
And I'm like,
well how shark?
He is it like,
and they're like,
well there's this,
there's a salmon feed out there and,
and,
and they feed off salmon or this one place I went to this place called green
island in Australia where we had to swim across the shark pit to get to the
break.
Yeah.
We just swim across the shark pit where the guys I was surfing with had seen a
great white and they told me about how they got off and got out of the water and
they'd climb up on the rocks.
And I'm like,
too.
So the whole time I was out there,
I'm like,
I'm not enjoying this.
And the Bar,
I was surfing with Brazilians and they don't give a fuck fucking crazy.
And they're just like,
stop being such a pussy.
And I'm like,
oh,
you're so crazy.
I'm like,
I just don't,
I'm not fucking feeling good about this.
This is just so used to the water,
especially if they're from Rio.
So used to surfing,
so such a part of the culture down there.
When Ari and I were there,
we went to the UFC in Rio.
Great fucking time though.
It's a God damn.
The food was delicious.
Woo.
They love their meat.
Oh my God.
Fucking Brazilian.
The navy,
we eat Brian and I eat it like Fogo de Chao all over the country.
And they're there.
Those,
the,
that's like one of our favorite places.
We find out,
you know,
we pull into a town,
we find out there's a fogo.
We're always like,
oh,
well it's mark this one off the list.
But these,
these places in Brazil,
this is the motherland.
It's got the,
you know,
Chew Husker Maria style.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I fucking,
I ain't so good.
And you plug that in to you,
but it like at nine o'clock in the morning,
man,
not even like seven o'clock in the morning,
we were up and we were,
you know,
cause we're all jet lagged.
We're looking out on the beach,
seven in the morning,
people were planned swimming,
running on the beach.
They're like so much more active and healthy than Americans.
And you know what's funny about Brazilians,
the men dance to,
they're like black dudes,
they dance.
There's nothing wrong with it.
They love dancing.
And they look at like white dudes that don't like it and they're like,
you're an idiot.
They're like,
you'll never get so much pussy.
But then it's fun.
They're there.
I hang out with Brazilians in Australia.
And it's funny because there's kind of like an Australian Brazilian kind of
clash and there is,
yeah,
it's,
yeah.
Is that,
because a lot of Brazilians come to Australia and then they surf and they're
kind of aggressive and there's a whole like culture clash between the two of
them.
But I thought of aggression on the beach,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like supposedly like I serve Venice breakwater every day,
which is supposed to be legendary for,
for all this fucking crazy,
a localism.
And I've probably had like three or four incidents in my life where we've almost
gotten out of the water and fought,
this is my friend,
you need to take some Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Have Your Brazilian
friends sit down with you and just show you basic position.
One Dude was fucking give me shit one day and all I did was he goes,
oh yeah,
let's get out of the water.
I'm going to beat the fuck out of you.
And I was like,
really?
You're gonna beat the fuck out of me?
He's like,
yeah.
I'm like,
okay,
uh,
then you're going to jail cause I'm a cop.
And he went,
what?
I go,
LAPD,
motherfucker,
you just threatened to call your line.
You Bitch.
And he went,
he went,
uh,
okay.
So silly.
It doesn't work like that off duty cops don't have like some sort of a special
license to be cons,
but,
but no,
he was being the current.
And there's,
there's some locals that just fucking take it like,
hey sure he was,
I mean this is our fucking area.
You can't surf here.
That's so silly.
But I was as a cop ever done that.
I've never personally had a problem ever in Australia though with like
Australians are totally cool about like,
no,
it's more of an American thing.
I think it's the localism I've seen in American way works.
Why is it,
is it because there's a shortage of waves?
Yeah,
there's totally a shortage waves and because everything's on the computer now,
like there's all these sites,
it'll tell you where the good waves are.
Everyone has gone to the same places and so really only one person can catch a
wave.
Does it easier to learn how to surf now though?
Like cause you can kinda like get lessons online.
Are there more people surfing?
It's somebody just twittered me today and said tell Jody of Kelly Slater on the
show.
Yeah,
I met Kelly.
I interviewed him at one of the UFC is really,
he loves you if say,
yeah,
he's a good friends with Bj Penn and he trains too.
That's,
that's Bj Penn I think is the one that did the crossfit workout.
That named it fight gone bad.
That might be who it was.
It probably makes sense.
Yeah.
Bj,
Bj apparently is thinking about making a comeback.
He decided to take a lot of time off after the Nick Diaz fight,
but apparently the,
the rumor is that,
uh,
Dana talked to him.
I haven't spoken to day and a couple of days,
but Dana talked to him and he said he wants to fight.
That'd be awesome.
That'd be nice if he wants to,
if he actually wants to,
you know,
but if he's not motivated,
there's two Bj's is Bj the world beaters,
like one of the greatest fighters of all time.
And then there's unmotivated Bj who just doesn't find as well.
I mean it's really that simple.
It's like Tyson after,
but it's hard,
man.
Bj has been at the top for so long.
You know how hard it must be to try to keep the motivation up to,
to train so hard.
Your body,
any supernatural too.
He's not,
he's not fucking around with growth or anything funky.
He,
he's,
he's 100% natural.
I mean it takes vitamins and supplements,
but he's not fucking around with anything that's going to aid in his recovery.
His motivation sucks because everyone else is probably doing that.
A lot of dudes do that Todd Duffy guy that we were talking about,
he's one of the youngest guys that's a got a,
a,
an exemption for hormone replacement.
You know,
in some guys have it,
uh,
because of head trauma.
You know,
some guys have hormone replacement because when you're,
if you're in a sport like football or boxing or MMA as well,
when you're getting tagged in the head,
it's very possible to damage the pituitary gland and the studies that they've
been doing on,
uh,
on,
on high level combat athletes,
those seem to indicate that there's a certain amount of head trauma will lead to
a drop in your testosterone,
a significant drop.
And it's not from guys that abused it's guys that were clean.
So it's not,
there's two ways to damage your system.
Well,
there's a bunch of ways,
but one of them is that you can,
you know,
disease obviously get damage you,
but one of them is,
um,
you can,
uh,
do steroids when you're young and you do a lot of steroids in your balls,
just quit.
You just shut them down and break them.
And so then you need hormones.
Literally they have to ingest.
These are strong.
Yeah.
But those guys,
it's always like I'm stirred,
you know,
crazy looking dudes,
Arnold Schwarzenegger in his prime type dudes where it's like there's no way to
achieve those levels without like completely jolting your body,
you know?
So that's one way.
There's another way you could,
if you get bit by the resilient and wandering spider that kills your Dick shot
up forever.
Spider called the Brazilian wondering spider called a Brazilian wandering
spiders that when it stings you,
it gives you an unbelievably painful hard on where your body,
your dick is literally spliting like,
like a hot dog that you sliced and then put it on the grill.
Oh,
lumps.
When you cook it,
your whole body's in mass.
In the Amazon.
It's the most toxic spider known to man.
Really?
Yeah.
If it doesn't kill you,
it breaks your Dick here that Australia,
they even have the fucking and that too because that's clearly,
it's got some pretty bad ass.
Wider.
Australia is missing good drugs.
That's what Australia is missing.
You don't have the Iowasca there.
Brazil,
they have something similar.
There's an aboriginal uh,
Elixir that's,
it's just not nearly as common,
but it's very similar in the fact that it is a,
it's based on conduct.
The,
the two elements,
having a Mao inhibitor and having a,
a DMT that you can take orally.
I've never,
I haven't spent much time with like aboriginal people in Australia,
but my next trip over a and I go about twice a year,
uh,
I've got a buddy who's decided he was a pro basketball player and he's,
he now has like his new thing,
he's filming documentary.
He's about,
he goes way into the Bush,
into the fucking Bush and he's filming documentaries and I'm going to go with
them and kind of,
I've gone up to Darwin to the northern territory and just like kind of
like looked around and stuff,
but I haven't gotten into it and I lost it.
Australia is a huge continent and as big as American,
but most of the people live along the coast,
right?
Yeah.
There's only 20 million people like we have,
what is it,
like 300 million?
They have like 20 million.
Oh my God.
And they all live around the coast.
So great there.
It's amazing what a great fucking contrasts plays ever.
I love it.
When we were in Sydney,
I was like,
Brian,
what did I say?
What do you think?
I would say if I was in Sydney,
uh,
you wouldn't go into the bush.
No,
I would say I could live there.
Great place to me because everywhere we go,
that's cool.
Like when we were in Atlanta,
I was like,
well you sit and I only say it,
but you'd like to be on the radio station that morning.
We like,
I think I might live here fairly seriously.
Head problems convincing.
Mrs Rogan,
obviously I moved,
I moved to Colorado.
I was ready to,
how'd you read
what happened there?
I want to know that.
Why you went to the Colorado?
I did want to live in Los Angeles anymore.
Yeah.
I don't blame you.
Well,
first of all,
travel for work,
right?
I do the UFC.
I travel,
I do comedy.
I travel.
I needed a local comedy scene.
Denver has one of the best in the country.
There's a club called the comedy works in Denver and my friend Wendy,
who runs it,
she does an amazing,
no,
she's never booked me.
Ever.
Never ever.
Why?
I don't know.
Talk to her.
You're hilarious.
That's Wendy.
How dare you,
Edie,
if does he find comedian?
I've always talked to level.
Well,
you should be able to pack places now because of your podcast,
right?
I mean it's,
it's,
you don't know,
talking shit.
Jim Jefferies,
our friend and idiot,
they have a podcast together.
Yeah,
it's doing,
it's amazing how much fans come out now.
What's funny and they're fucking idiots.
Like I was in Atlanta and these guys work shirts that said Eddie EFT has aids
and show up at my shell,
like a whole bunch of wearing these eddy gift as aid shirts because Jim,
you know,
did that Google bomb,
right.
And uh,
what did he do?
What was the Google bomb?
He told all our fans to Google.
Eddie gift has aids.
And if you do that,
if enough people do it,
when you search my name,
that's the first thing that comes up in the cache and yeah,
and I'm getting them back.
I got a whole fucking plan.
But uh,
but so yeah,
if you type in MDF,
it's the first fucking thing.
And even my mom asked me about it.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's kind of why at other,
well,
she was like trying to get tickets for her friends to my show and she'll,
she typed an idiot left in any of those aids comes out.
I've had ex girlfriends call me and go,
we have to talk.
It's,
so I did Kevin and beans,
April foolishness last week,
uh,
at the Gibson amphitheatre just before I go on stage.
You know,
like,
I'm not a big believer in intros.
Like a lot of comedians want their specific intro or make me look good or when
I'm like,
if I'm funny,
I'm funny.
It doesn't matter what the fuck you say.
You could say ladies and gentleman,
Eddie,
if that's all I care about,
I don't fucking,
I seen him on this.
You've seen him on,
if they've,
if they know who I am,
they know who I am.
They don't,
it doesn't going to hell.
And I hate community.
You'll tell them I'm the guy from the shattered and commercial or I'm the guy
dot.
No,
and the one person that's going to go,
oh yeah,
that's not going to help you.
So I just want Eddie gift.
But they had these nice interest for everybody.
So beer mug that works on the Kevin and been show,
it goes,
hey,
uh,
you like slayer,
right?
And I'm like,
no.
He goes,
I thought you like slayer.
And I'm like,
no.
He's like,
because I was going to go,
he likes slayer,
he likes Tequila and he likes this and he has aids.
Perfect.
And I go do not intro.
Really.
I did not want this next comedian come to the stage,
has aids perfectly taken that and run with it.
Run with it.
So because thank God he told me too,
cause you know when you're walking the stage and you get hit with that.
Like,
like when I did my first comedy central TV show,
it was premium blend years ago.
Harlan Williams hosting and my hey there butter cup muffin top pumpkin biscuits
and my whole closing joke all about star
wars and Harlan right between like goat from his to mine.
You know they have mine totally scripted.
They know exactly what I'm going to say but Harlan cause he's the host and he's
a celebrity.
He's allowed to do whatever you want.
Does this big star wars bit?
No and that's my closer and I'm like walking on the stage just going,
it's over.
But it's still,
yeah.
Did that to Johnny Sanchez during a TV table.
This is Heartland's original men.
See it did it on purpose.
We do that are used to do guys bits right before you would do their closing bits
for,
he'd bring them up.
Why?
Listen man,
there's a reason why we went after that guy.
It was never heard that yeah,
they were doing like local slam or one of those fucking shows and uh,
Johnny Sanchez is a very funny guy and a great dude.
Really,
really nice guy.
And he had this great joke about a neighbor that actually really happened to
them like this.
This is crazy Persian guy who would always accused people parking in this
parking spot and he,
he gets pissed and he speaks his broken English.
It's really funny.
This mother fucker does the bit like as he's bringing,
oh it was Johnny's closing bits.
So he's going on to a television show that he does.
He does his closing bit.
That's beyond like,
like just trying to get a laugh.
That's like sociopathic.
Oh,
it's called.
Totally.
Yeah.
There's a pathology there for sure.
What,
that guy,
yeah,
unfortunately.
But you know,
I haven't heard anything about it year,
so I'm,
I'm hoping he's not doing any morning.
He's got his shit together now.
But uh,
yeah,
at the time.
So when you would happen just a total accident?
Yeah,
it was total accident,
but you know,
at the time I'd probably only been doing comedy like six years or so,
and I'm just like,
oh,
that's devastating off fuck here.
You know,
like you don't even have like good stage legs in the first six years now.
And I was throw it all wa but it's,
it's more than that.
It's the,
it's the whole fucking TV aspect of it where you're like,
well what if I change my final bit now?
Are they going to get mad?
Cause you have to have everything approved.
You do a bit.
Can you do a star wars bit after he does it?
Is it possible?
It was a,
it takes a lot of window that sales.
Right.
I really did.
And it,
and it was a shitty joke anyways,
but,
uh,
you know,
looking back,
I'm like,
we were in Vegas and,
um,
it was me and I think it was Joey Diaz,
maybe Eddie Bravo,
I don't remember.
But we were there for some fights and Harlan was playing at the palms,
so we went to see him.
Great Guy.
I Love Harlem.
Every time I see him,
you know,
he's just say there fella.
He's like super friendly just as a warm guy.
Anyway,
he goes on and he's fucking killing.
We're having a great time.
Awesome.
The fire alarm goes on like a tension,
you know something?
It was like,
it was,
it was a,
was it a fire alarm or an emergency alarm?
I don't remember what it was like there was,
but there was a,
oh,
it's crazy.
Really loud thing.
And Harlan played through it for 10 minutes.
Wow.
He's that he,
yeah,
I've watched him deal with every,
like he's that guy that's funny.
And every circumstance,
you know what he is,
he doesn't get mad about shit.
You know,
like he really didn't get mad.
Yeah.
And it was kind of funny that this guy was in the middle of his show and he was
never like,
but it was really fucked up was we were just sitting there like,
this ain't real like a real terrorism drug.
They could have been fucking oh Taliban running in with machine guns and shit.
Oh,
fucking the,
the Japanese tsunami would happen and I'd be sitting on the beach because I
don't trust any,
like anytime they're like,
we need to evacuate.
I'm like,
fuck off.
Most of the time in college I stayed eight like my 22nd floor dorm room.
Well,
a fire alarm was going.
Oh my God,
they're crazy.
Because they would always make her go down.
Come back up.
That's better than burning to death.
Trust me,
you're silly.
You're a silly man.
I didn't trust them.
I want to know that.
Why you went to Colorado so that well,
well I just didn't want to live in la anymore.
I think my theory is,
this would have always said is that there's,
there's too many human beings in one spot and it's just like rat population
density studies where they take rats and they put two rats in this cage and
they're fine and they put four and then by the time you have a bunch,
you have all these,
these crazy behaviors,
you know,
rats sit in the corner shaking and the nutty rats,
aggressive rats.
And I just think there's a,
there's without a doubt,
you get a certain amount of energy from people.
You get a certain amount of energy from the people that you're around.
And if you're in a tense neighborhood,
you absorb a certain amount of that tension.
It's very difficult to relax.
And whenever I've been to places that have a lighter population,
like boulder for example,
boulder,
Colorado is only a hundred thousand so where you were living and they drive
around,
everyone's driving slow,
no one's tense.
There's no one running red lights.
It's not all the continents of Los Angeles doesn't exist there.
And Yeah,
you've got to deal with some snow,
but you deal with a nicer class of people.
It's because it's people that aren't under the gun and you take people out of
this environment like me and you put them over there and you calm down cause you
know,
ask anybody about Los Angeles.
There was just a study that people hate people from Los Angeles and I said
that's cause we always tell you,
you know what the temperature is.
People,
when you call someone,
Hey I'm man,
I'm in Boston,
really 70 degrees here,
I'm wearing shorts.
You know there's that.
But please,
this is a real issue with why people come here.
Like what you said they should call it.
Daddy doesn't love me on the side and their shits taxing after awhile.
It's taxing and it's also that,
that overpopulation thing,
like you take away the traffic out of La,
it,
it take away the population.
It's a pretty nice place,
beautiful mountains and oceans and it's great.
But fuck,
it's not as nice as boulder though.
Not as nice as Australian looking at the,
the visuals of boulder.
But it was amazing to me was that you could drive around and you'd look at these
mountains.
It was like,
this is like,
if this was a painting,
it would be worth $1 billion.
It's like the most incredible natural piece of artwork and it's in front of you
every day.
It's like that is,
yeah,
and it has a tangible effect when you're looking at mountains,
like there's a place in Colorado I really liked called evergreen.
It's a suburb of Denver and my God,
the view,
there's insane.
I looked through this one house and I just sat on the porch and I couldn't even
fucking believe that they would allow you to live there.
How long,
how long did you stay for months and why'd you leave?
So my wife got pregnant.
Oh,
you can't,
you can't.
We were way high in the mountains we were at,
um,
where we were was 3000 feet above boulder,
so it was 8,000,
500 feet.
It's really high.
And you,
you,
you can't be pregnant up there.
First of all,
even regular women that live in boulder itself,
which is 5,000 feet in Denver,
they had,
there's a really high rate of premature births.
Oh Wow.
Because of the oxygen,
like it's,
there's no air up there,
man.
I would work out in my yard and do these kettle bell drills that I do and it's
you'd,
you'd really feel like there's not enough air in the world.
You can't get any air.
It's thin,
like walk up the stairs and you're tired.
Like it's really thin up there.
So for her it was brutal.
It was the,
the morning sickness was intolerable.
And then on top of that,
it's just a real trick you up there when it's snowing and we were in the
mountains and mountain lions and bears and shit.
Like there's a lot of real study of cats.
Why a dog got killed,
killed by mountain lions.
That happens a lot.
Drink.
That sucks.
It's just not,
it's very rare that it happens because there's so much for them to eat up there.
You know,
it's very rare that one will attack a human.
But you every now and then could be in the wrong place at the wrong time.
And you find an old one that has like,
you know,
it doesn't have sharp teeth anymore,
but it could still kill Ya.
Ah,
that would kill me if my dog,
but it's so gorgeous up there,
man.
I was,
my wife says is the calmest I've ever been.
She's ever known me and my life was when we were living at,
you need to go to Australia.
You know,
Australia is cool,
but you know,
there's,
first of all,
it's not America.
So that would bum me out.
And then,
uh,
it's Cunty as America could be.
It's still where I was born.
I'm used to it here.
I could get used to it.
Like in terms of like,
if America was the apocalypse in Australia was the way it is.
Yeah.
That kind of happened to me where I went there and I was like,
oh,
I could do this.
I still have family here.
And that's the thing.
I can't be that far from my family otherwise.
Yeah.
I like arches.
There aren't.
You went and he's,
he lives there.
Right.
He's got this big house and lives there and he's a huge superstar with it.
People don't understand what a big superstar he is.
Like if you walk down the street here in America with like a famous,
like,
like even you,
you,
how famous you are,
you know you're going to get recognized.
How like if you walk down the street,
how often would you get recognized?
Depends on if there's a bunch of young dudes with tattoos.
Obviously young dudes tattoos most likely.
Yeah.
But him like we'll go through a town like Adelaide and every,
every five feet someone's going to arch barker and it's like they saw,
it's like chick seen Brad Pitt.
Wow.
And I go fuck like when you come to her,
I started hanging out with them.
I was like,
you're fucking like super famous.
You're like Pauly shore in the 80s flavor,
you know like,
like use that right.
Cause you,
cause you think about it like that's back before people had 500 channels and
before people had the internet and before like where you only watch like like
five things on TV.
That's what they had back then.
Well they've just lately,
I mean they used to have,
they don't have cable.
They do have cable but not a lot of people have it.
Do they,
do they get American channels?
Yeah they do.
And now everybody,
because of the Internet,
everybody's watching everything on the Internet and DVDs and everything and,
and they,
they take a lot of our movies and put Monte but shitty movies and Shitty sitcoms
and stuff.
Like when it was impossible or give you at a DVD from there it was a different
villages still is.
What does that at pal and NTSC I don't know.
But wait a minute pal and NTSC doesn't not exist with a VHS.
Isn't that VHS DVDs,
DVDs,
game with VHS.
There was an issue with that too,
right?
Wasn't there?
It's always been,
it's a signal that I believe that there are TVs you so I think,
cause I remember I got a,
an multi-region DVD player just so I could watch the Ali g show from England
cause this is a totally different kind of DVD if you play like on my Mac,
if I play a pal DVD it'll say you only have five more feedback.
And then it and my,
my old,
my old Max switched over.
What the fuck is that man?
What does that Bull Shit I had to buy like software to convert it back.
And it was like really you it was a third party software.
It was fucking crazy.
That's so stupid.
That doesn't make any sense.
It has something to do with the cameras.
Cause I remember we were editing when I made my movie,
we had some cameramen overseas and then we'd have to have all those,
all that tape we are shooting on mini DV at the time we'd have it have a
converted and,
and it was such a process and I'd go why?
And they're like,
actually I think there's more pixels or something.
And a pal.
I'm not sure.
It makes sense that there's two different formats so it didn't agree on and
what,
it doesn't make sense as your computer can switch back and forth,
but only five times.
Why do you Brian,
do you know?
I have no idea.
I never saw that before.
I'm sure we're going to get,
all of us are going to get emails and twitters and I'm sure the tweets and I'm
going to get to come roll.
I'm going to get yelled at for something was inaccurate.
Well you should see the fucking
well and gets the abuse Calli guess when he comes on here.
So I was talking about us history.
Just Shit just misses a whole chapter somewhere along the line,
not this,
you know,
he's not super knowledgeable about a lot of shipping.
Is One of those dudes who would read a book and then yell at you for not knowing
this five minutes after you read it.
Do you realize,
okay Chapin
such a great impression,
but you believe him too.
Cause he,
he tells he's right.
A lot of times it's so passionate.
He's a great storyteller.
You know,
that's the one of the beautiful things about having friends like Callen or you
are Jodi is or Jim or anything.
When you have friends that are comics,
it's like God damn it,
it's so entertaining.
You know when people talk about like doing this podcast like well you guys are
putting out so many podcasts,
was it a lot of work?
Well there's,
there's work to it.
You know,
there's,
you know,
you have to upload it like Brian has to do the dirty work.
But as far as like though the work of actually sitting down and talking,
it's like it's the funniest time ever what we do anyway.
Well it's,
it's a crazy thing.
It's like we never really took advantage of the resource that was us in our
friendships until podcasts came along.
You know,
pot,
like when we had radio shows,
if you would go on someone's
radio show,
it's very rare that you could just bring it all your friends with you on the
radio show and put on,
you have to interact with these djs.
And that was their thing and that was it.
So it's like you never really got a chance to like sit down purposely.
Like we're gonna meet at three o'clock,
we're all gonna sit down,
we're going to smoke some weed,
we're going to drink some coffee,
let's talk some shit about all kinds of things.
Like that would be a great thing to do.
But nobody ever schedule shit talking sessions.
But because the fact that everyone is going to hear about this and it's going to
be something that goes on the Internet and people going to enjoy it.
And then we started doing it.
And the coolest thing about it,
like what I love about your podcast is you,
you guys like you just talk.
And comics are interesting people because we have a lot of time on our hands.
So we,
most people have to do their job and that's why they're really good at their job
because they do it,
we do our stand up and then we have a lot of extra time and our,
our standup comes from our extra time of us thinking and philosophizing.
And in doing so,
we all acquire lots of hobbies and lots of things.
We get into and we're,
we're all of a kind of weird kind of mindset.
Like to be a comic you have to be a bit OCD,
a bit neurotic.
There's all these different aspects of it.
So you compile all that,
you've got like a certain type of individual.
And so we all have a knowledge base.
It's like we have generalized knowledge,
not a lot of specialized knowledge and,
but we have a general knowledge of all these different things and then we're
able to also spend humor into it.
It's fucking,
it's like the greatest people that hang out with.
It's,
it's amazing.
And I'm glad that everyone,
people go,
aren't there too many podcasts?
No,
it's fucking great.
Well not only that,
um,
I think it's really cool that right from the beginning everyone has a sort of
helped each other out and everyone has promoted each other.
Yeah.
You know,
from the beginning,
I mean Corolla and I'm doing Carolla show a in a couple of weeks and when I'm
doing it,
we're going to record these little things where,
you know,
I do see an ad for his podcast.
He does an ad for our podcast.
That's awesome.
But we always do that.
I mean,
you know,
we,
Ari,
you know,
texted me,
said,
hey,
I got this gig coming up.
I'm recording in Denver.
Can I do your podcast?
Yeah,
sure.
Corner.
It's like we all work together.
Yeah,
I can't thank you.
You helped me with the fund.
It's really cool.
I mean it's,
it's a beautiful thing to do.
It's our podcast.
This is no line.
I'm not blowing smoke.
We get to see the numbers on Libsyn and how we're doing.
We get our biggest spikes when we win.
Like I'll do your show,
like,
oh,
that's awesome.
Oh,
when I do,
Jim gets on your show and never talks about our podcasts.
So fucking nothing happened.
He sells more DVDs if got,
but uh,
but I get on here and plug talking Shit and uh,
seriously it,
like you can see and what happens is it spikes and then it'll plateau for a
while and then I'll do like your show or Jamiel wars or Corollas or something
and then it'll spike again.
So it's showing that like the audience is coming and they like it and they stay.
And that's why I always tell other guys with pockets,
I'm like,
come on my show and be a guest.
You'll get,
our audience will then start listening to your show.
If they like you on our show,
they're going to listen to you.
Like there's a guy,
McCarthy use
a funniest fucking guy alive.
He's not a comedian.
We have them on our podcast and he's just,
you know,
you found these guys,
right?
He's just a guy who found hanging out in the comedy dude fucking the funniest
fucking crazy dude that skill.
His gift in life as being an interesting dude to be around.
And he has a podcast now on national lampoon,
the Brian McCarthy interview show and he's just fucking like,
he came on our podcast one time and just told us,
he told three stories where three of the best stories I've ever heard in my
life,
one,
he fucked a postop transsexual and it tells the story.
And the episode's called Amani Eat.
This dude's can't.
And it's the funniest story you'll ever hear because he's so brazen about.
Then the next story he told,
he got arrested smuggling pot from Jamaica in a boom box when he was 20 years
old.
Oh No.
And stayed in prison for a month because he didn't want to let his mom know.
Oh No,
no.
So he wrote it out,
you know,
you know they set your trial,
but you can have bail.
You can post bail and get out.
So I stayed in prison for,
he just stayed in jail and the other dude was crying every day that got caught
with them.
One to call.
He's like,
no,
my mom will kill me.
Oh my God says Mama's been terrible.
Kidnapped his Mama.
Scary than JDA.
Yeah,
that's what he said.
Imagine that hot.
He,
he's just the funniest fucking dude.
So I like that.
Like a guy like that who the industry has turned their nose up.
It won't fucking give him like Joey does.
Yeah.
Until Joey Diaz started coming on this podcast,
people didn't realize how brilliant he really is because they see him on stage.
He's talking about eating ass,
touching new muffler and I'm like,
we don't want to have nothing to do with this guy's too crazy.
But then from the podcast,
people become like big,
big fans of his and they realized that he's a,
he's complex.
There's a,
we're real lucky and having a comedian's for friends,
you know,
for other people,
like I'm saying this right now and for sure there's someone out there going,
I don't want to fucking needy ass comedian as my friend,
but we understand each other.
Like,
you know,
like a guy like you or a guy like count or me or like we,
if,
if you and I were,
if you know,
if I didn't even know you,
but we ran into each other in an airport,
you know,
and I'm like,
what do you do?
I'm a comic.
Ah,
I'm a comic too.
What's up?
Are you gigging?
What's going on?
If you do,
it would be instant.
Like it,
as long as you're not a Douche bag.
Well,
Stan hope wrote that great,
great fucking blog about that.
I,
we're running into comics,
no,
about why he hates Dane Cook.
And you're not allowed to.
And,
and it was fucking genius and it was about like,
but he said to his fans,
basically,
he's like,
at the end of the day,
if I saw Dane Cook in like an airport lobby or whatever and I saw you,
I'd go hang out with Dane Cook.
Wow.
He's like,
cause I'd have,
cause I'd have more in common with Dane Cook.
Then you and I could talk to Dane and we have shit to talk about.
He's like,
where are you?
You,
you know you're a fan.
Like uh,
sorry.
That's a weird way of separating yourself from all your people.
No,
no,
no.
The point Stan hope was making was he was saying like that everybody,
like he had a problem with Dane and his problem was Dane called him a hater and
said that he was jealous of him.
And he's like,
I'm not jealous of you.
You know,
I just,
it,
he explained why and it was a valid,
he said,
look,
nobody was jealous of Chris rock or Jon Stewart or Dave Chappelle.
When they got famous,
he goes,
we're not jealous of you were angry with Annie and it was a problem because they
had this thing over stand up,
calling them on the phone and it was just does,
it's a whole long thing.
But at the end of the day he was saying,
you know,
like here's my problems with them and it's a comic having a problem with a comic
over comic issues.
Like you,
people that don't like Dane now like you fans that don't like Dang you're
jumping on the bandwagon not knowing why
as sort of,
I disagree though,
because I think a lot of people don't like people cause it's just not their
style.
And if you like a certain type of music and I don't like it,
I'll shit all over that music.
He goes,
yeah.
But I mean that's just what people do.
Yeah.
But I sounded lightened thing to do.
No,
I think there's though,
now in comedy there's so many people are aware of not just comedy,
like what they like,
but the clicks of comedy
[inaudible] who's an easy target.
A safe target.
Yes.
And it's like,
it's like for a while Dan was getting bashed,
show hard that I wanted,
I just wanted to get on the other side.
He'd be like Jane supporter.
I'm sure people would have loved to have bath.
Chris rock if he had like a chink in his armor or even Dave Chappelle,
if he had something like wrong with Woodward,
he was doing,
they'd like to go after him too.
You know?
I think when,
when people look,
when you're real successful and they look,
if they find something fucking other,
they're going to harp on it.
But if they don't find something,
then you're Chris Rock.
You know what I'm saying?
And you're just,
you're just a brilliant comedian.
That is what it is.
And not stealing is not not a bullshit.
He's just,
you know,
and I think that's really where it's at because it's not just black guys.
It's what Louis C K nobody hates on Louis Ck.
Nobody hates on Louis Ck.
He's doing,
I'm sure
Brian,
you know what I mean?
I know manager,
you've,
you've might've been with this guy at one point.
Dot.
James Dixon.
You know,
James Shore Know James when he,
uh,
he said to me when I was like,
great guy,
great guy and wild man.
Some of the best advice I've ever had in common,
some smoke hash under glass,
small cash under a glass.
I didn't know identity,
put it on a pin.
He lit the Hash.
I thought he was a drug addict because I was like 25 and shit.
I was like total straight edge.
Fucking just been able to see it like,
like somebody smoking a joint around you or somebody who this loser James James
said,
best fucking advice I see
goes.
Uh,
he,
I,
I used to call them,
you know,
I was like 24 years old just doing co it's debt starting.
Stand up.
Well what do I do?
I don't know.
And he'd go,
just be undeniably funny.
And I'd go,
but what about like there's,
they're coming to see me and should I,
he'd go,
just be undeniably funny.
And I'd go,
what,
what else should I go to acting be undeniably funny?
He goes,
that's your job.
I'll do everything else.
Just do that.
And a good agent.
And then I said to him recently,
I was like,
you didn't mention,
you got to be undeniably lucky too.
He goes,
yeah,
I've seen a lot lucky guys
and they've made it big,
but they've never stuck.
They don't stick around because they're like lottery winners.
Yeah.
He's like,
you got to really have it.
And the guys that are like you're saying like Chris Rock and well you should,
you'd also,
it has to be a passion of yours.
You know,
I've spent a lot of time doing things that were not a passion of mine and I
spent a lot of time doing other people's stuff like other people's TV shows or
other peoples and was often times,
but there's this just such a massive difference between doing something that
you're really passionate about,
you know,
and and putting all that energy and that reward that you get from that.
There's nothing like that.
That's what,
that's where real success comes from.
Real success comes from transferring that passion and then people go and
experience it and they feel it and it's pure and it's real.
You know,
when your,
your standup is really just sort of a vehicle for getting out the greatness.
It's not inside of all of us.
You know,
whether that greatness manifest itself in piano playing or the manifests itself
and you know,
you're,
you're a great basketball player or you're fucking awesome and editing videos
that,
that what that thing is just,
it's just finding that in yourself and,
and providing something to other people that gives them this energetic reaction.
You know,
they're sitting in the audience.
It's laughter.
You know,
if you go to see like honey,
honey,
you know,
it's,
it's not laughter but it's this other crazy,
weird,
satisfying thing.
What's beautiful music.
You know,
it's like that,
that is what it's all about.
And unless you're doing that,
you're not going to be happy unless you're finding whenever the fuck it is in
life that makes you do something.
And it always seems to have something to do with how other people appreciate
your work.
Cause it's like if you're a chef,
you want people to appreciate your food.
If you're a carpenter,
you want to appreciate someone,
appreciate what you've done.
And you built this house.
It always seems to have something to do with giving something or producing
something and creating something that other people feel good about.
Whether you're a lawyer who gets guy out of a tricky situation because you
really love the law.
You have this passion for the law,
like whatever it is,
it always seems to come down to how much passion do you have for for it and how
much does it have positively affect people.
That's like how you got to kind of structure your life and that's why a lot of
people get really lost and they just try to do things for themselves.
They just try to get ahead for themselves and just try to do well for
themselves.
And in doing so you're like a person who's got like this and massive vitamin
deficiency.
Like you're taking all this vitamin D and you're taking all those,
but you don't have any sea.
There's no senior,
your system,
you're missing vitamin love like everything you're doing.
It's like a forward move me,
myself and Ah,
I will cause shellfish till you know,
till I make it.
I don't have time to be nice,
but you don't understand.
You don't have a choice.
You will not be happy.
You won't be successful if you make it,
you'll be miserable.
You wind up fucked up on booze or drugs or whatever.
You're,
you're at an imbalance point.
If you're thinking solely of yourself,
it's like your greatest work and your greatest feelings will all come and
creating something that you're passionate about that other people are going to
enjoy.
It seems to be,
that's like the,
that is a big key to life that it has to be to really truly be a happy person.
You have to be doing something that other people are enjoying as well.
Oh yeah.
There's fucking doubt about
that.
That's because like when I hear people take antidepressants,
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't have any,
any imbalance and he mental about that I know of,
but if I do it workable,
you know?
But when I hear people taking things to make them happy,
I go,
wow,
man.
Match.
Then imagine not being happy.
Imagine like spending most of your time not being,
I don't feel that because I'm happy all the time.
No,
I mean I'm not happy all the time.
I'm,
I'm pretty happy person.
And people have said that to me.
They're like,
well,
for a comedian,
you know,
comedians are all fuck you,
you're pretty happy.
And I go,
well,
I look for happiness.
Well,
you're intelligent.
You gravitate towards happiness.
Yeah.
I tried to find all the things that make me happy.
I go surfing and makes me happy.
I go workout at the gym.
I like that.
I love my girlfriend.
She makes me happy.
I found her,
you know,
like my dogs.
They make me happy.
I go out and hang out with my friends.
Like do the things that make you fucking happy.
It's like when people go,
I hate my job.
I hate my life fucking chain.
I can't.
Yes you can.
This way,
it's not easy.
It's certainly not easy to,
it depends on how,
you know,
if you swam all the way out to the middle of the ocean and go,
I got to get back to shore.
I can't you,
well,
you got here,
it's going to take a long time.
Yeah.
You got to get better the same way you got sick.
It's not easy to get back to shore,
but you know,
if you would swam only a few feet and didn't get a mortgage and didn't have kids
and didn't have 20 years and waiting for your pension,
and then if you just get out in six years,
then you'll have full health insurance until you're dead.
You know,
there's,
there's people that like cannot ever pull the trigger to jettison themselves.
I just had this argument with a friend who was telling me they're depressed and
I said,
well,
like,
look,
what do you need?
You know,
what would be like,
let's take the steps.
And they're like,
uh,
can I get a coconut water?
They're like,
uh,
you know,
that's not the thing you say to someone that's depressed.
That's,
and I'm like,
look,
I'm here to say let's,
let's find the past.
I mean,
man,
what does that mean?
That's not the thing.
This is not you.
One universal thing you say to someone that's depressed and I haven't yet.
I haven't read the book about what I'm not supposed to say to people that are
depressed.
I don't know what's going on in someone's head cause I know for sure I'm wired
different than other people.
I've reacted different and how much of it is nature,
how much of it is nurture the fuck do I know?
I don't even think that's an exact science,
by the way.
I think there's a lot,
a lot going on in the,
in the school of Psychology,
that's a lot of,
it's theoretical and there's a lot of,
there's a lot of shit going on.
There's still don't know exactly why a person is the way they are.
So I don't know what the fuck makes somebody happy.
Have you seen the stuff that did the teachers,
the class on happiness at Harvard,
he teaches a class.
There's a class,
it's a,
I think it's Harvard business school and you can watch some of his stuff.
I'll tell you what would make me happy.
Teaching a class on being happy would not make me happy.
Well,
this guy,
no,
but when he talks about some cool shit,
he apparently it's like the most coveted class at Harvard like itself.
Like it signs up and you can't get into it cause it's the first one is easy
credit that
makes you happy.
But he's got something like he's young,
he's done a lot of studies on happiness,
which is pretty amazing.
And he starts stuff like,
uh,
I think
one of them was,
he said that after $70,000,
like in America,
after you make so many thousand dollars,
your,
your happiness is not congruent with your,
with your financial level.
That's bullshit.
That means you've got a bad friend,
doesn't know what the fuck you talking about.
Who you hanging out with,
dude,
what else or something.
We can do some damage with some money.
Hold on,
hold on.
I got a friend who has,
who literally is a,
I shouldn't even talk about this.
I'll let you say,
I've got to figure out how to filter it.
I got a friend with a lot of money,
like a lot of money and this friend use the money.
For awhile he didn't.
And then I was like,
dude,
do you know what you can get with what you have?
And then it clicked one day and then he had slipped and slides on the top floor.
The fucking win with chicks naked,
fucking running down the slip and slide.
Well fucking uh,
uh,
midgets dressed in or little people dressed in storm trooper outfits are serving
him drinks.
That's awesome.
Like he went and did it as a no,
but I mean he just,
he just did the Michael Jackson thing where you have so much money.
You're like,
I want to live in a tree and I want to have a monkey and I want to have,
you know,
like you just started going fucking crazy and like,
let's see how we can just spend this money and you know,
the next thing you know,
he's just totally fucked up.
You know,
just,
you know,
there's just,
it crippled a mentally and,
you know,
he ended up in Rehab and all kinds of shit.
Like I can't happen when you're looking for that empty happiness or you're
looking for happiness through substances.
You know when people say,
Oh,
you're a hypocrite dude,
you're getting high all the time.
First of all,
I take weeks off.
I don't have to get high all the time.
I liked it in high.
It's good for you.
I think.
I think marijuana is one of the only vices that I really don't have any problem
with.
As long as you'd get all your other shit done in your life and you use it to
enhance things that your dad was just going to say.
But my agent in Australia is the fucking greatest guy that's ever lived and my
agent gets everything done on all the time and he's fucking amazing.
And,
and,
and he joked with,
he wants and he said about like getting high like you can be productive on ma.
I know so many math,
like productive fucking people with marijuana,
super productive.
A lot of writers beyond like people get you to like the mentality I am.
If I smoked pot,
I'd be way more productive because when I used to smoke it I was better.
But I,
I just can't smell.
When you said one bad thing that too,
did you uh,
what did you tweet me about this?
We talked about this on the green room.
He tweeted me,
he was in horror,
just couch law.
Joe was my go to guy and I thought here's a guy that's going to talk me down off
the ledge.
Like you just need your,
your,
your medicine like,
and it could be like,
like a lot of people say milk helps you when you have like a bachelor from
Sherman and even if it doesn't,
you have that in your head.
Somebody told you milk milk around,
you ever have that happen again?
You drink a glass of milk,
you'll feel it.
I started getting panic attacks from it and people told me,
like Bert told me to get
a w with Xanax and I'm like,
I'm not taking Xanax.
And he's like,
stick with the milk.
He's like,
take Xanax.
I'm like,
I'm not taking Xanax.
And he goes,
he just put in your pocket.
He goes,
you don't ever use it,
you,
but you know it's there.
It's like it's silly bitch.
I think Burt was the one who told me that sounds like,
oh no,
no,
I go,
do you ever,
you ever have a panic attack and you guys fuck every day.
And I go,
what do you do to stop them?
He goes,
have kids.
Wow.
Cause I said I was having,
that's what it was.
I was self indulgence has get,
it's a back seat.
I was at,
yeah I was having trouble getting it.
A lot of the like fuck the anxiety was happening on planes and stuff and like
when I'm claustrophobic and they locked the doors,
so the plane,
I'm like,
I want off this fucking plane.
I look flipped out.
I'm like,
I get it.
Yeah.
I'm always afraid I'm gonna be that guy they're holding.
I have like a claustrophobia thing of like,
like you couldn't have fly so much,
so much.
And,
and,
and I don't like,
I don't like sitting on a runway.
I like when we take off.
I like when I don't,
like when we pull up the gate and they're like,
oh,
we're not gonna be able to pull into the gate for another 20 minutes.
That's when I'm like,
what is it about complete fucking control?
That's what it is.
It is a control freak.
He got to,
someone said something to me a long time ago,
this comedian Tony v,
and it literally,
it became a tool that I use in my life.
He was driving back and forth from Boston to New York on a regular basis and
that's a long drive.
A couple hours at least,
even if you're going fast.
And I said,
uh,
I go,
how are you doing that every day?
And he goes,
I just go zen.
I just,
I'm in my car and I go,
this is what I'm doing.
I'm driving the car.
And I just,
that's,
that's how much time it takes and I don't worry about it.
I just do it.
And I was like,
wow,
that is the way to think about it.
Because you know,
it's like you'd start doubling,
God dammit.
Why don't they pull this thing,
then you realize like how much energy is wasted on something that you're never
going to have any effect on it whatsoever.
And if it takes two hours to drive somewhere,
it takes two hours to drive somewhere unless you hit a fucking wormhole and find
yourself on the other side somehow,
you know,
it takes two hours to drive there.
You just have to go zen.
And he,
it's a tool.
It's a tool I use now.
So whenever I'm in any sort of a situation where,
you know,
if it's bad weather or if it's what I just go,
this is what I'm doing now.
I heard some fucked up shit recently about flying and pilots.
This girl I know told me that like,
I can't say who it is,
I can't say what airline or whenever,
but she knows it's a pilot and uh,
she,
he was talking about how like how you had to go to work and he,
and she goes,
oh,
that sucks.
I get tired and she goes out.
He goes like,
that's why I can't wait to go flying's like that's what,
when I get the best sleep,
I guess like when they take off the,
and then the copilot is fucking sit there and push a button,
go to sleep,
and they get wake woken up,
you know,
when her,
uh,
like near the city.
Why is it scary?
Because that's just like,
if you imagine like going into a cockpit of an airplane,
everyone's fucking sleeping.
One
guy stays awake at a time.
I think they probably do shifts.
But,
um,
I think the,
the way those autopilot things work,
unless there's a situation where they're running the crazy weather and they wake
right the fuck up.
I don't really think it's that big of a deal.
It seems like it should be,
but I mean,
it's just all like,
you're driving on a windy road,
you're just flying in a direction.
They put it on autopilot and it just fucking guess.
I knew a chick who's a pilot who,
uh,
and I'm not going to tell you the airline,
but she,
uh,
she fucked another pilot while they were flying commercial airline.
What a dirty,
and she wasn't flying the big ones,
but she was flying like maybe like a two and a one like two seats on one side,
one on the other leagues.
She's up there fucking riding a dude who I know and I thought about that.
I'm like,
I would like that.
I would like to know that if there's a female pilot up there,
she's fucking up there.
That makes me feel good.
Are you should,
if you're an hour on a plane was the woman,
the woman comes on over the loudspeaker.
Hello,
this is your pilot and Argos.
What a woman.
What
it real like.
Oh No,
I hate that uncomfortable shit,
dude.
Don't do this.
Don't do this right now.
Jim Jefferies was on a plane.
That dude died.
Whoa.
On the plane with his wife.
Oh my God.
And he dies and it's like fucking leg England to Australia or something.
So He's dead and the dead.
I go start to smell or did they do and he goes,
they like took him to the back and covered them with like a blanket and I'm
like,
oh my God,
what did she do?
He goes,
she has sat there.
Oh my God fucking car.
I can't imagine.
I watched the lady go into a seizure and was really creepy man.
It was weird.
It was right after September 11th so she was right behind on a plane.
Yeah.
She starts to start seizuring and they go,
it's okay.
It's okay.
This happens sometimes I guess epileptic people,
they just,
they just go into seizures.
Yeah,
yeah.
I've seen that a bunch.
My friend Jay,
Jay Helfrich,
he's a a pool player and spent most of his life like gambling and playing pool
is playing this guy and the middle is set.
The guy falls down to the ground and starts bucking and kick in and making these
noises and the guy was losing and he assumed that the guy was doing it to try to
get out of the game.
Cause like,
you know,
yeah,
it was,
dudes will do things to shark.
You sure they'll do things to distract you.
And he was looking at it like,
wow,
this is a new one.
This guy is faking a seizure.
But really the guy was an epileptic and it was like a normal occurrence.
Like he'd be in the middle of his day and he would just fall to the ground and
start bucking and twitching and they didn't help him.
He didn't help him die.
Someone helped him.
Someone came over there.
There's a,
there's a video on youtube,
I think you can find it and we played it on our podcast.
There's a comedian that died on stage in England,
died,
fell off the stage and died.
Well fucking Gallagher's.
I like 18 heart attacks offstage.
Know this guy just fell off the back of the stage.
But he was that kind of comic too.
So they think it's part of his act and then eventually his son runs on stage and
kind of is like,
this isn't a joke.
That'd be kind of a cool way to go.
I agree.
You know why not?
It's better than you would kind of ruin the show.
Yeah,
maybe it would make it better with your bombing and that was how you pulled
yourself out of it.
Um,
I saw a guy do that on a golf course.
Once he died,
he stayed at God know somebody misses a Putt and he just does a faint.
And I thought that's a fucking cool trick that like,
like you're going pretty far to like show how bad that affected you.
And I'm sitting there and all of a sudden I see a woman jump off like over the
railing of like a six foot high porch,
jump over it and just sprint down to it.
And I went,
oh,
that's,
and so I just ran and called nine one one and I was like,
fuck man.
Amazone uh,
he died.
They said he was dead when he hit the ground,
which is heart attack or something.
Yeah.
Sometimes it just stops,
man.
If a blow a piston in your car and just driving on the highway and bang black
smoke,
you pull over the side of the road.
Have you ever thought you were having a heart attack and then you burped?
No.
I get indigestion and I've gotten a bad,
I've gotten into gestures so bad where I'm like,
fuck,
I'm getting these like crippling chest pains.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I guess this is it.
I'm going,
that's crazy.
And then all of a sudden I'll burp and I'll be like,
I'm going to live.
Whoa,
whoa.
We really have you ever had that?
I get it all the time.
I get my heart every day.
I'm pretty good.
The heart beats freaks out.
It's,
it's mostly all because of like,
oh yeah,
I had onions on my subway,
spoons can fuck shit.
Like that fucks me up.
I don't know.
I don't get it anymore cause I'm,
I'm a nerd about my diet.
I eat the Paleo Diet and uh,
and I fucking am religious.
How did you become this fitness nut mean because you,
your choice of attack is like crossfit.
Like how did that I,
I ran track in college like all my life and then got into like,
I was an ocean lifeguard and I was doing like ocean lifeguarding competitions
and stuff like that.
And then I got into like triathlons and I was always doing it on the slide.
It was almost like I'd go out and party really fucking hard,
like really hard for like two weeks.
And then I would go like,
feel shit about myself and try to clean up.
And then I'd go like,
and it was like here and there,
here and there.
And then finally I just said,
all right,
this has got to fucking stop.
I'm a mess.
Like I was,
I,
when I'd go to the UK,
I'd spend three months over there where I would drink at lunch and we would go
out for lunch for beers and I would drink til show time,
drink,
you know,
they bring me a couple of pints backstage at the show,
do the show,
and they go out and party all night.
And I'd come home from England just feeling like a piece of shit.
And uh,
and I was like,
all right,
I better do something.
So I started,
uh,
I started working out and then,
I found that I was,
I liked bodywork.
Heck a body like body weight exercises like pull ups,
push ups,
sit ups stuff.
Cause I didn't want to get big and because I liked the run still and,
and I found the navy seal workouts.
So I started doing navy seal workouts online and then they said,
uh,
Eh,
we don't have a workout today.
Go to crossfit.
And I was like,
what's this fucking crossfit thing?
So I went to crossfit.
I'm like,
what is this fucking weird community of there?
And it's fucking weird dude.
I mean it's a weird group of,
it was a weird group of people.
The ideas,
there are different exercises every day,
every day you're shopping,
you're just a shocking your system with metabolic conditioning.
It's combination of gymnastics,
weight lifting and sprinting.
And uh,
and it's,
it's the whole idea is the prepare for the unknowing.
Like you never know what you're going to get.
Like in weightlifting,
you might do your legs one day and then you take a week break to let your
muscles recuperate.
But if you're a,
an uh,
mixed martial arts guy or a cop or fireman or a military guy,
you don't know what's happening day to.
So they might throw fucking legs at you day two and day three like you don't,
so you,
it's not good though.
Not good in one aspect but good in another.
Your adaptation levels start getting higher and higher.
Your ligaments,
no,
not necessarily.
Because if you learn good form,
which is what they try to teach you is learn the proper technique and then you
won't have the injuries and you won't have the problems but aren't you like the
whole idea about working out,
he's supposed to give your body time to recover.
Well they use it like a battle,
a seesaw if you like.
I'm a three day on,
one day off guy,
three days on,
one day off three which is what they prescribed.
But you look at the guys who are now the competitive level,
the guys that are competing on that are the top crossfitters in the world.
Like if you look up this guy rich Froning jr just watch any youtube video of
him.
You're going to go,
this guy's fucking in Newman in human like this is impossible.
What he's fucking doing.
The impossible.
Brion pull up.
Goggins iron man,
G,
O,
I n s iron man on Youtube.
There's this fucking dude who's a,
he's a navy seal and it's some of the fucking crazy dude who came in second at
the cricket games last year is a,
is a seal.
They calm the toughest athlete on the planet.
This dude like regularly runs.
Um,
where's it say,
does it say Goggins iron man,
the upper left hand corner?
Yeah.
Click on that.
This dude ran a 48 hour race.
It's a mile track and you run for 48 hours.
Just wrapping your head around it.
That's ultra Merrick's.
No breaks.
The guys,
the guy that runs crossfit and endurance.
But what it is is it's your,
you're pushing your limits.
Listening.
I know on the blacklist,
just to test my soul to see it.
I'm about to see in 150 mile race in [inaudible] 75 when I feel really bad,
that's when you know that's the only time you can find out.
What do you mean by is all about what,
what you're made of to find out and seeing this dude a lot to myself,
limits of the human soul and every day I'm trying to see if I have limits.
I run anywhere from one 25 one 50 in a week,
so I'll try put him about 450 miles a month
running.
Usually every day.
I wake up at three o'clock in the morning and I run anywhere from 10 to 15 miles
in the morning and then I live about 25 miles from work.
So I,
I get my bicycle,
commute into work,
do a normal work day at lunchtime around noon I'll run again and he's an ultra
marathon,
eight miles,
whatever it may be.
Come back work and around five 30 I arrived back home 25 miles on my bike.
If I'm feeling good,
I've considered doing one in the house,
get off the bike and do like a short three or four or five mile run.
That's my everyday life.
So I don't this train like an hour or so.
I tried it until something is uncomfortable and then national,
you know who you are,
she's fucking Christ.
There's a thing called crossfit and
it just never ends.
This for me.
I've done some races where you're on a one mile track and you around for 48
hours straight.
So imagine reminder,
48 hours of running my mile track.
It's not like you're sleeping.
You're,
you're running for 48 hours,
70 miles you can get,
I want to talk about mine torture.
I think it's so fast.
Any of those dudes that are constantly trying to explore the limits of what you
can pull off.
We were just talking about this yesterday.
We had Andy Petranek on who owns crossfit La on our show and he was talking
about where it's come from and what it goes.
It used to be the guys,
uh,
they used to give awards for if you could do like 40 pull ups like that was,
there's guys that blow out 107 in a row now like I can do for your straight arm.
No we do a kipping pull up but I can do 40 in a row like w without even
thinking.
Can you really simple?
Do you grab it,
a palms outward or pumps towards you?
I go palms outward and it's just like when we jumped rope you jumped two at a
time.
Always a,
now it's advancing to three at a time and like three swings under your feet each
jump and it's just,
you're learning that like man just evolves and gets better and better and adapts
that things like we have a workout called,
we have a workout called Murph where you run a mile,
then you do 100 pull ups,
then you do 200 pushups,
300 air squats,
and then you run 300 air squats and then you run,
you can break it up in any order.
So like we do like five 10 15 five,
10 new,
you talking about Hindus squats,
we'd go all the way down to your heels.
Oh,
you're the crease of your hip has to break the crease of your knee.
So your hip has to go,
but you're not.
Your acid is not touch your heels,
your,
your hips.
They'll have to go below your knee crease.
And it's not quite as hard as Hindu squats,
but I can't imagine that you can do all that and do 300 so you run a mile,
then you do a hundred pull ups.
Oh my God.
200 pushups,
which we do chest,
a hand release,
pushups.
So your chest touches the ground,
you release your hands and then go up and you're thinking that's easier.
No,
it's harder to trust me.
Your chest is touching the ground on every pushup.
And then you do 300 air squats.
Then you run a mile.
That's called Murph.
That's a workout.
Now add to it now a 20 pound weight vest.
Uh,
but without a 20 pound weight vest.
A guy in our gym did it in like 24 minutes and he did it like it takes me like
36 minutes or something to do it.
He didn't like 24 minutes and he did it.
Uh,
he was doing his miles in like five 15 or five 20,
like a mile.
He would run in five and then go do all that.
No he didn't do that one with the 20 pound vest.
[inaudible] it goes substantially higher with the vest on,
but the times are just coming down and down and down.
And the,
the pull ups and the Po and the weight,
the injuries are people getting more,
I think people do sustain injuries just like they wouldn't MMA and everything
else.
And we have a big problem with that.
And then,
and I think it was the NFL,
we talk about that on my show a lot.
Cause like my,
my girlfriend's dad's an ex NFL football player and he's got two artificial
hips,
two knee surgeries and two shoulder surgeries there.
They become like bionic men cause dome.
He's pretty good.
He's a very successful businessman.
But like,
like I got a buddy who's a crossfitter who's a super bowl fucking,
he's a crossfitter now,
but he was in the Superbowl,
this guy's won the super bowl,
he's won national championship in football and Nash and the High School
Championship and football.
And he is a,
you know,
he's got all these injuries from football but like he'll tell you that crossfits
like keeping them in the game because like there's nothing better for your back
they say then doing deep back squats.
Huh.
You know,
like it,
it,
that's fundamentally what's good for your spine.
Now if you're doing it with improper form,
you're going to fuck yourself up.
You're going to find,
you're going to go deep.
And when you do a deep squat,
like how,
how far down is your asco?
Um,
same,
same kind of thing where I'm going to,
mine goes really deep because that's where you're going to get your
explosiveness at the top.
Like people don't understand,
they think,
oh,
I don't want to go that low.
And I'm like,
I want to get as low down as I can because right there is where your,
your nerf are going to fire and you're gonna be able to explode on and we need
to get you to do Jujitsu.
You're overflowing was manly exercises and you don't have an outlet for them.
Well,
you can see your progress other than the exercises themselves.
You know,
we've got to get you in and you want to come tonight.
What are you doing today?
I'm loving it.
You know what it'll be.
It'll be the fucking panic of me.
I've been choked out before.
Like,
Oh,
you won't know son.
You don't spar your first day,
man.
You learn some moves and you,
you,
you're learn positions with people.
It's not like you're just allowed to get mauled.
Also Callen told me once I was dogging account cause I wanted to take Krav Maga.
I dinner one night with John Mayer and a John Mayer was,
is a big fucking Krav Maga.
He loves it.
He loves that chip.
And I had just been robbed.
I had a guy break into my house while I was there.
Whoa.
I'm upstairs in my house.
I come down the steps is this black dude standing in my house.
And I go,
what's up dude?
Which he trusted us.
It was an inside joke,
sorry.
He goes,
ah.
I'm
looking for David King.
And I go,
uh,
who's David King?
He goes,
no,
it goes,
is this his house?
And I go,
no,
he goes off,
it must have the wrong place.
And he walks out the door and I'm like,
fuck.
So I kind of walked out and my dog was a puppy at the time.
I didn't want to run it around.
So I follow him out and then I take the dog back up as I come back out,
I go,
Yo Dude,
what,
what?
Who's David King?
And he kind of looks at me and then he starts to run and he's already,
he's got about 150 meters on me and I,
I was like,
I ran a division one track and in college and I was a sprinter.
And I'm like,
this dude has no idea how fast this white guy is and I'm going to fucking catch
him.
Why would you,
I'm like,
I'm going to catch this because he,
you know,
he was just in my house.
He just fucking robbed me.
And I'm like,
what did he have two when I took the dog back in,
as I go inside,
I see my pants were on the couch and I look in the wallets,
out of the pants and everything stripped out of the wallet.
So when I go back out,
I go,
I,
that's when I sprinted after.
And uh,
so I started to die for your critical,
no,
I,
I don't know.
It's the fucking,
this is what I'm telling my aggression problems.
You should really,
so I chased this dude,
I'm like fuck,
like,
and when I turned the corner,
he had just disappeared.
Thank God cause I live in Venice and my buddy's like,
dude,
he's a shoreline crip.
He would've come back that night and put a bullet in your head.
You're an idiot.
So,
so you know,
in retrospect,
but,
so I,
I tell John Mayer about this is you got to read the book gift of fear.
He's like,
read that book.
And he's like,
and then go take Krav Maga.
So I tell Collin I'm going to crawl in the and Callen cause no,
no,
not you.
You will bring it on yourself.
He's like,
if you know how to use it,
it's like having a gun in your house.
Yeah.
He's like,
why?
So I don't have a gun.
I don't have fucking anything.
That's good to tell people on the Internet.
I'll tell you what.
I got guns.
You'd come to my house.
I'm gonna choke the fuck out of you if I got a hold of you.
I don't,
I disagree with count.
Um,
I,
if anybody had a lack of self control as a young man,
it was me.
And it's one of the reasons my parents didn't actually want me doing martial
arts cause they were worried that I was going to start using it on people.
That was the number one fear in our house.
I had to convince them they wouldn't do that,
but you wouldn't do that.
You'd get self disciplined,
but it allows you,
you know,
at least if that guy jumped on you,
attacked you or it didn't have a knife or something,
you know,
where was a weapon?
You're in trouble.
At least you could kind of defend yourself.
You know,
you,
you put yourself in a better position and it's a great way to exercise a great
way to blow off steam.
And it's interesting,
you're actually learning something.
You're learning a language.
The language of how to,
how to strangle people.
How do we had a break arms?
How does he know how to get to positions and you,
you learn these moves.
I mean the interaction between two human beings and they're grappling.
There's an infinite number of positions and moves in different places to go to.
So it's like,
it's a very intellectual,
Jujitsu is really completely under appreciated as an intellectual exercise.
I already threatened enough go.
He
wouldn't do it,
man.
I never threatened people.
You wouldn't do it.
I've been doing,
I've been doing martial arts my whole life.
I've,
I fucking have.
I don't think I've ever said I'm going to kick your fucking ass to I do it.
I do it on stage once a year.
That's crazy.
I'll never do that.
At least once a year somebody will push me like um,
like you were saying Harlan,
just like I laughed through everything but at a certain point I have a snap
where I'm just like so dumb.
That's going to get you hurt man.
You'd come to Jujitsu with me tonight.
What are you doing tonight?
Come Watch.
He doesn't want to touch other guys.
That'd be silly.
Where do you go?
Do you go to 10 Hollywood come to me.
I got,
I have to go to hell.
Not Tonight.
There is no tomorrow.
Rocky like Apollo creed said no tomorrow and I got a bulging disc right now.
Just watch.
I'm not sure.
I'm not telling you to get in there and get crazy.
Do you have a bulging disc close on it?
Some guys,
Ronald said someone will take care of that.
Well listen man,
been a fun pause cat.
The flood,
we've done like three hours man.
Totally free by pretty close to hours in something I'm always doing.
Always a good time.
My brother.
Always good to see you.
Always good to run it anytime you want to.
Come on man.
Fucking awesome.
I love it dude.
And I got to come on here.
We'll do it.
We'll work with fans.
Ask Us,
constantly do it once a week now.
So what are you doing?
We do it.
What we've always done once a week.
We do Monday night and a,
that's the problem.
Cause you wrestle on Monday stuff most of the time.
But I'll,
I'll take,
I'll take the night off.
I'll do it in the day.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
Eddie left and Jim Jefferies have a podcast on iTunes.
It's fucking awesome.
Please check it out.
It's called Co.
Come see me at the Hollywood improv.
How do you not talking shit because they pulled it off.
Talkings hit talkings hit.
Oh,
I get it.
So you just moved to space over this.
Very,
very clever and I'm talking,
it hit hit.
Talkings hit ladies and Joe Hollywood improv.
This,
uh,
this Saturday two shows I'm headline.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
The Hollywood of Improv on Melrose,
one of the best clubs in the whole country.
It's an amazing spot.
It's like really intimate seating and it's going to sell out.
So if you're,
you're interested,
go online and just Google.
You know how to do that shit.
You're smart.
You gotta rush the stage.
Oh yeah.
Somebody's got rushed in the stage there.
Randy can,
do you know the story?
I don't know him but I saw the whole thing and he has no idea why the guy went
up there.
I just went crazy.
Yeah,
just fucking deck.
What's he talking about when the guy is doing a joke on California and the guy
had,
the guy wasn't heckling previously.
There was no fucking reason or I'm just crazy.
Yeah,
that happens.
You go out there in the world,
you can run into crazy and that's why I should know judges.
That helps.
It helps.
It would help you tremendously do especially telling me threatening people once
a year.
Come on,
Sun Life is short.
Enjoy this shit.
A thank you to everybody.
Thank you for all the,
all the love on Twitter and Facebook and all that stuff and we appreciate the
fuck are you guys,
and thanks again for everybody who came out to Atlanta this past weekend for my
filming could have been better.
You guys are the shit.
We're,
we're beyond lucky to be in the situation where we have a show like this.
I don't know how the fuck it happened,
Brian.
Do you know how it happened?
The internets.
Yeah,
but I mean,
something happened.
It all coalesced together in some sort of a magical form and we're very
fortunate and we,
we,
we think about that all the time.
We were very appreciative.
So thank you very much to everybody tomorrow.
Mad Flavor,
Aka Joe Diaz.
Fuck.
What the fuck?
Cock sucker.
He's going to come down to regale us with stories of old school criminal
adventures and his ball sack,
which by the way got him kicked off of Facebook,
purple veins and Mary Eric.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
Cover of his documentary.
He decides this is Joe Rogan.
This is going to be the cover of my documentary.
It's gonna say it's gonna.
This is it.
It's beautiful.
It's my balls man hanging out there with fucking does a vein of beautiful vein
in my,
and I'm pulling up and it says where I got my balls.
That's the name of my,
of my special,
my documentary.
Like wouldn't that be like dad's balls then?
Yeah,
you would assume vagina.
I mean it's just,
it's a metaphor,
but so he's going to change it and it's going to be the,
the,
the actual picture.
He's a two pronged attack.
The first prong is show people's balls,
create a shock wave,
which I guess he's achieved.
And then pronged too is a different photo than it has already prepared.
Clever Joey d is,
he's the man.
Can't wait.
I'm going on tour with them.
Yes you are.
And when and if,
and the first GIG and Columbus is sold out right?
The first day.
First show and Columbus is sold out.
Second shows.
There's some tickets left and it's May 17th May 18th that's Cleveland.
And how do people find out about this?
How they get their tickets?
It's good.
Death Squad.
Dot TV.
It's right at the top.
Powerful death squad.
Dot TV.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
so that's it.
We'll see you guys tomorrow and thanks for everything.
We can't.
I can't thank you guys enough.
You guys are the shit.
Um,
thank you to the fleshlight for being our first and original sponsor of the
podcast.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and are in the code name Brogan,
and you will get yourself a big,
fat,
juicy,
15% discount for a real good product.
Any did you want one?
I have one.
Do you want one?
I show access.
Okay.
Eddie,
it's going to fuck one tonight.
May.
Perhaps he has a girlfriend.
Maybe he won't do it tonight.
I'll take it on the road.
If you're really brazen,
if you really,
I'll just do it in front of her.
Whoa,
you're an animal.
I love it.
That's crossfit coming out of here.
Um,
uh,
thanks to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and it makers of Alpha brain,
shroom tech sport,
shroom tech,
immune end,
new mood,
the five HTP enhancing supplement.
All the answers to all your questions are on [inaudible] Dot Com oh and and it
please Google nootropics.
Do your due diligence before you take any supplements.
Don't expect miracles,
but expected to actually increase your brain's ability to process information
and then it makes you,
it makes you talk cleaner.
It's a,
it actually pumps up your body's ability to produce neurotransmitters.
It's all very controversial,
but something that I absolutely stand by and believe in.
The first 30 pills when you order it,
it's 100% money back guarantee.
You A,
you're not going to get ripped off.
You don't like it.
You try it like this isn't for me.
You get all your money back.
You don't even have to return the product.
All right,
that's it.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the Alpha brain link and during the code name Brogan and you will get
10% off any and all orders.
Kettlebells are common.
They should be here probably in the second week of May,
the first wave of Kettlebells,
the a the second way we're going to blow your fucking mind,
but they're,
they're taking a long time to build,
but there are so ridiculous.
How ridiculous that I just can't wait to talk about it.
I'm not even exaggerating.
You guys have your own kettle.
Then I'll show you something that's going to blow your fucking socks off.
MDF.
That's it.
You dirty bitches.
We love you from the bottom are are our black monster hearts.
I don't even know what that means.
I'm stealing.
Lady Gaga has names now.
See Ya.
Bye.
I ran out of words.
Okay.